bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur publique Sénat difficile fin d'année
pour le gouvernement à la haute
assemblée avec le rejet hier pour la
deuxème fois consécutive du projet de
loi de programmation budgétaire ce texte
fixe pourtant les grandes orientations
du gouvernement en matire de finances
publiques et notamment fixe le déficit à
3 % du produit intérieur brut en
revanche les sénateurs ont adopter le
compromis trouvé avec l'Assemblée
nationale sur le projet de loi qui doit
permettre la création de la BPI la
banque publique d'investissement avec ce
vote des sénateurs le Parlement donne
donc son feu vert à la création de la
BPI qui était je vous le rappelle le
premier des 60 engagements de François
Hollande retour donc ce matin sur ces
textes bonne matinée à tous
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture de programmation des finances
publiques pour les années 2012 à
2017 dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Jérôme Cusac
ministre chargé du budget merci Monsieur
le le Président nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion dans cette enceinte d'évoquer
cette loi de programmation des finances
publiques je n'ai pas d'éléments
nouveaux à apporter au Sénat sauf pour
préciser que la disposition qui pourrait
être adoptée en dernière lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale je veux parler du
Crédit Impôt compétitivité emploi cette
disposition ne modifie pas l'équilibre
des finances publiques si en revanche
elle permettrait par son financement
d'abaisser le taux de préléement
obligatoire de manière plus sensible 1
an plus tôt et ce faisant euh d'être de
permettre à notre pays d'avoir une
accélération dans le processus
d'assainissement de ces finances
publiques pour le reste il n'y a pas
d'éléments euh adoptés ou devant lêtre
en dernière lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale qui modifi cette loi de
finances plurannuell et c'est la raison
monsieur le Président pour laquelle je
n'interviens que très brièvement et de
cette place afin de euh d'indiquer
pardon à à la Haute Assemblée ce qui est
le le seul élément de modification
tangible que le gouvernement propose à
l'occasion de cette 2e lecture du projet
de loi de finances
pluriannuelle merci Monsieur le merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur François
Marc rapporteur général de la commission
des finances vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues la commission
mixte paritaire chargée d'élaborer un
texte commun
euh sur le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques a
échoué le 6 décembre dernier par contre
conséquent l'Assemblée nationale a
examiné le texte en nouvelle lecture la
nuit dernière cet examen a été marqué
par l'adoption de plusieurs amendements
du Gouvernement ce qui ne doit pas être
regardé comme une surprise mais comme la
confirmation de l'engagement pris devant
le
Sénat souvenons-nous du contexte dans
lequel nous avions examiné ce texte
chers collègues nous étions le 7
novembre et la veille le Premier
ministre avait annoncé un Pact pour la
croissance et l'emploi comprenant un
crédit d'impôt de 20 milliards d'euros
financé pour moitié par des hausses de
prélèvement et pour par des baisses de
dépenses si tous ces mouvements sont
globalement neutres sur le solde puisque
la réforme avOcatiOn est intégralement
financée il modifie à la fois la
trajectoire pluriannuelle des dépenses
qui va être minorée 10 milliards et la
trajectoire des mesures nouvelles sur
les recett est aussi réduit de 10
milliards il était trop tôt le 7
novembre pour décliner toutes les
conséquences de l'annonce du cice
d'autant plus que ce crédit d'impôt
n'avait évidemment pas encore été adopté
par le Parlement c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement avait marqué son respect du
Parlement en déposant au Sénat un
amendement dressant la liste des
articles susceptibles d'être modifié
pour tenir compte de ce
cice dans le contexte qui nous arrive en
nouvelle dans le texte qui nous arrive
en nouvelle lecture les conséquences sur
la trajectoire pluriale du vote du cice
dans le cadre du collectif de fin
d'année ont pour l'essentiel été tiré le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques qui
va être installé au début de l'année
prochaine pourra donc se prononcer sur
les ion 2013 en se fondant sur des
données cohérentes attons-nous de
rappeler au préalable que comme prévu
les trajectoires de soldes effectif de
sold structurel ne sont pas modifiés
notre objectif de moyen terme qui
constitue l'indicateur désormais
essentiel aussi bien au regard du traité
sur la
stabilité reste bien l'équilibre
structurel en
2016 il est toujours prévu comme
François Holland s'était engagé pendant
sa campagne d'atteindre une situation
proche de l'équilibre effectif en 2000
2017 en revanche la répartition de
l'effort pour respecter ces trajectoires
entre recettes et dépenses est modifiée
en conséquence le ratio de dépenses
exprimé en pourcentage de PIB prévu pour
2017 est ramené de
53,6 à 53,1 % cela résulte d'une
révision à la baisse du taux d'évolution
volume des dépenses publiques qui est
ramené de 0,7 % à 0,5 % en
moyenne le ratio recette sur PIB prévu
pour 2017 et quant à lui réduit de 463 à
459 puisque l'on remplace 20 milliards
de prélèvements obligatoires par 10
milliards de prélèvements obligatoires
et 10 milliards de baisses et dépenses
pour les recettes nous savons que la
réduction de 20 milliards d'euros de
l'impôt sur les sociétés sera
partiellement compensée dans un premier
temps par une augmentation de la TVA à
laquelle s'ajoutera ensuite la fiscalité
écologique pour les dépenses il restera
à fixer la répartition des efforts
supplémentaires entre les différentes
catégories d'administration publique
puisque ces précisions ne sont pas
encore connu peut-être en serons-nous
plus dès le mois d'avril lorsque nous
examinerons le programme de stabilité
avec sa transcription aux autorités
européennes au-delà de la prise en
compte des modifications rendues
nécessaires par le vote du cice le texte
qui nous revient à nouvelle lecture est
identique ou presque à celui de première
lecture en particulier s'agissant des
dispositions relatives à la gouvernance
des finances publiqu et qui prévoit
notamment une durée limitée pour les
niches fiscales une évaluation par 5e
chaque année de l'ensemble des niches
fiscales un rapport sur les taxes
affectées ou encore de nouvelles
modalités d'évaluation préalables des
investissements publics j'ajoute que
l'Assemblée nationale a repris à
l'article 19 relatif aux modalités de
contrôle de l'exécution de la
programmation un amendement que la
commission des finances du Sénat avait
adopté avant de rejeter le texte et qui
prévoit que les données d'exécution
doivent être présenter à périmètre
constant je vous ai présenté je crois
l'essentiel des modifications apportter
à ce texte en nouvelle lecture par
l'Assemblée nationale j'insiste à
nouveau sur l'importance politique de
cette loi de programmation qui traduit à
la fois l'engagement du président de la
République de revenir à une situation
proche de l'équilibre budgétaire en 2017
et la mise en œuvre de nos engagements
européens à compter 2013 lorsque nous
onons ramené le déficit sous le seuil de
3 % du PIB et que nous devons
respectecter les règles d'équilibre
structurel figurant à la fois dans le
TSCG et le volet préventif du pacte de
St
notre capacité à respecter nos
engagements constitue un élément
déterminant de la crédibilité de notre
pays avec le dispositif issu de la loi
organique et la création du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques nous disposons
maintenant d'un organisme indépendant
qui attestera du respect des engagements
qui ont été pris la nouvelle majorité
depuis 6 mois qu'elle est aux affaires a
donc à la fois fixé des objectifs
ambitieux en en matière de finances
publiques et empêcher qu'il soit encore
possible d'embellir la présentation de
l'exécution j'y vois encore une marque
du courage dont fait preuve le
gouvernement c'est pourquoi la
commission des finances a adopté ce
matin un texte identique à celui issu de
la nouvelle lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale et je vous invite chers
collègues à lui apporter votre soutien
je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
générale dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame
Marie-Line desegoot pour le groupe umep
pour 15
minutes merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
une loi de programmation des finances
publiques c'est deux choses un objectif
et une trajectoire l'objectif mais
comment pourrait-il en être autrement
nous le partageons bien sûr le retour à
l'équilibre de nos comptes publics c'est
la clé de notre indépendance nationale
vis-à-vis des marchés financiers
notamment c'est permettre d'enrayer la
spirale infernale de l'endettement et je
rappelle que la charge de la dette c'est
46,4 milliards d'euros en 2012 la
trajectoire des finances publiques sur
la période
2012-207 prévoit un retour du déficit à
3 % en 2013 et l'atteinte de l'équilibre
structurel en 2016 et 2017 l'objectif
d'équilibre est ainsi exprimé en sol
structurel et non effectif soit corrigé
des variations conjoncturelles si le
groupe UMP partage donc ses objectifs
nous avons un sérieux problème c'est
celui posé par la trajectoire proposée
et ce pour trois raisons premièrement
cette trajectoire se traduit par une
évolution de l'équilibre
entreé fort sur la dépense publique et
hausse de la fiscalité fortement
criticable deuxièmement cette
trajectoire repose sur des hypothèses de
croissance discutables et troisièmement
cette trajectoire est pour le moins
sinueuse au regard des premiers mois de
mise en œuvre de votre politique de
retour à l'équilibre je commencerai par
ce dernier point votre virage à 180°
opéré suite à la publication du rapport
Gallois prouve en effet que la
trajectoire que vous avez défini
apparaît pour le moins désormais assez
illisible et brouillon et va de facto
faire l'objet de nombreuses contortion
puisque les recettes attendues sur la
fiscalité des entreprises près de 20
milliards d'euros seront déjà anilé par
un crédit d'impôt d'un montant
équivalent certes le coût du crédit
d'impôt sera compensé notamment par une
baisse des dépenses sauf que celle-ci
est repoussée à plus tard et que nous
n'avons toujours pas plus de précision
sur ce point concernant les dépenses et
c'est l'objet de mon deuxème point nous
regrettons que dans votre programmation
tous les efforts soient reportés à plus
tard au mieux à partir de 2014 il lu
fallu au contraire concentrer les
efforts sur la réduction des dépenses
publiques dès le début du quinquena
plutôt que d'augmenter massivement les
prélèvements obligatoires qui vont avoir
un effet récessif le matraquage fiscal
des ménages et des entreprises en 2012
et 2013 30 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation d'impôts en raison d'un
trop faible effort sur les dépenses
risque en effet d'avoir un effet
récessif important soit une diminution
du pouvoir d'achat et donc de la
consommation des ménages moindre
investissement fragilisation des
entreprises dont les marges n'ont jamais
été aussi faible et alors même que les
chantiers structurels relatifs à la
compétitivité et à la réforme de la
flexibilité du travail ne cessent d'être
reporté les objectifs en terme de dett
prélèvement obligatoire et dépenses
publiques tel que définie à l'article 3
illustre parfaitement ce yatus existant
entre la majorité l'opposition pour
parvenir à l'objectif d'équilibre de nos
finances publiqu pas d'effort sur la
dépense publique avant 2014 conjugué à
une hausse S précédent des prélèvements
obligatoires 1,4 points entre 2012 et
2013 concernant l'effort sur les
dépenses un certain flou ou devrais-je
dire un flou certain entoure le détail
des réductions que vous devrez pratiquer
par exemple à l'issue de 3 ans
d'ajustement budgétaire il n'y aura pas
plus de marge de manœuvre pour le
gouvernement sur les dépenses de
personnel sauf à reprendre les
suppressions de postes dans les
ministères prioritaires je pense à
l'enseignement la justice la police et
quand sera-t-il alors ou alors
accepterez-vous de baisser les salaires
le flou entre votre trajectoire de
réduction des dépenses mais elle met
également en lumière vos contradictions
la précédente majorité avait mis en
place dans la loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2011
à 2014 le gel en valeur de l'enveloppe
des concours financiers de l'État aux
collectivités territoriales le projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour les pour les années 2012
à 2017 prévoit que les collectivités
territoriales je cite contribuent à
l'effort de redressement des finances
publ ce qui se traduit notamment par la
baisse de 1,5 milliards d'euros de
l'enveloppe entre 2013 et 2015 réparti à
égalité c'est-à-dire 750 millions
d'euros sur les années 2014 et 2015 ce
chiffre de 2,25 milliards et parfois
évoqué en cumulant les diminutions par
rapport au niveau de 2013 pourtant il y
a un an vous poussiez des cris d'or
frais quand nous proposions de les
diminuer simplement de 200 millions
d'euros soit d' montant 10 fois moindre
il semblerait donc que l'exercice du
pouvoir vous ait fait prendre quelque
peu conscience des réalités et de ce
point de vue nous nous en réjouissons le
rapport Gallois semble également vous
avoir éclairé il prône de ce point de
vue de réduire drastiquement les
dépenses publiques il a été visiblement
à l'origine d'un véritable virage du
gouvernement ainsi dans le rappel des
annonces en matière d'économie François
Hollande dans sa conférence de presse du
13 novembre 2012 a annoncé qu'avec le
pacte national pour la croissance et la
compétitivité l'effort total sur les
dépenses sélèverait à 60 milliards
d'euros pour réaliser ces 12 milliards
d'euros d'économie par an pendant 5 ans
comme si engagé le président de la
République c'est encumulé
184 milliards d'euros d'économie qu'il
faut obtenir le projet pluriannuel
transmis à Bruxelles a é de 150
milliards d'économies réelle le compte
des économies nit donc pas selon les
calculs deinstitut français pour la
recherche les administrations publiques
leseffs réels en dépenses et non en y
incluant les effets incertains d'une
possible possible baisse des taux ne
sera en effet pas de 185 milliards ce
qui correspondrait à un effort réel
pluriannuel aboutissant à 60 milliards
d'euros d'économie en 2017 mais bien en
réalité de 153 3 milliards en effet par
avance le gouvernement intègre un taux
pluri-annuel cumulé un effet de ce taux
pluri-annuel cumulé de 31,6 milliards si
les perspectives financières se
dégradent à moyen terme indépendamment
des perspectives de croissance qui
produirait elle-même un besoin
d'économie supplémentaire spécifique bah
il faudra alors trouver jusqu'à 31,6
milliards d'économie réell en plus ce
qui est quand même considérable jevens
justement à mon 3è point concernant les
hypothèses de croissance le gouvernement
a adopté une approche volontariste
impliquant une croissance de 0,8 % en
2013 puis de 2 % au-delà mais si comme
la plupart des économistes le prédisent
nous avons un taux de 0,4 % de
croissance en 2013 puis de 1 % de 2014 à
2016 et de 2 % en 2017 bah il faudra
trouver 2,3 milliards en 2013 8,1
milliards en 2014 14,2 milliards en 2015
20,5 milliards en 2016 et 21 milliards
en 2017 nous voyons donc à quel point un
mauvais calibrage des prévisions
macro-économiques peut remettre
complètement en cause la trajectoire et
obérer la réalisation des objectifs pour
autre part à la suite de la crise le
précédent gouvernement s'était fixé des
objectif de réduction du déficit qu'il a
non seulement respecté chaque année mais
même dépassé dans l'intérêt supérieur de
notre pays nous vous souhaitons
également de parvenir à tenir vos
objectifs mais permettez-moi d'émettre
quelques doutes au regard de votre
manque de lisibilité de vos
revirements incessants de position je
l'ai rappelé à la commission des
finances ce matin de vos contradiction
de vos hypothèses macro-économiques qui
nous semblent mal calibré c'est pourquoi
le groupe BUP votera contre le projet de
budget le projet de loi de programmation
des finances publiques pour les années
2012 à 2017 dont s'il partage je l'ai
dit les objectifs il dénonce la
trajectoire merci ma cher collègue la
parole à Monsieur Thierry fouco pour le
groupe CRC pour 7
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur ministre mes chers collègues
lors de la première lecture de son
projet de loi qui avait été rejeté par
le Sénat nous avions posé quelques
questions sur le devenir de nos finances
publiques la France maintenant que le
corps électoral a parlé j'irai
manifester sa volonté de changement
doit-elle tout faire pour être le
meilleur élève de la classe
européenne devons-nous poser penser
l'action publique nos impôts nos taxes
notre système de prélèvement obligatoire
en général
notre manière de gérer les affaires
publiques et nos réponses aux besoins de
la société en vertu de ce seul objectif
l'équilibre des comptes publics en 2017
passant par la réduction des déficits de
tous ans réduction porté par la
croissance des recettes et la maîtrise
sinon la réduction des dépenses
devons-nous
satisfaire qu'après les décisions
fiscales de
2013 30 milliards d'impôts je dirais pe
S
nous marquions une longue phase de
latence de 2014 à 2017 sans aucune
mesure nous venant en contribuer sur la
période à accroîre significativement le
poids des impôts taxes prélèvement et
cotisation comme d'ailleurs nous le dit
l'article 2 bis du présent projet de loi
de programmation devons-nous penser que
la maîtrise des dépenses publiques
marquée par la réduction des crédits de
l'essentiel desmions budgétairees or les
priorités accordées à l'enseignement la
recherche la justice c'est la sécurité
et la seule voie qui s'offre à nous
devons-nous espérer que la croissance
spontanée née du comportement vertueux
des agents économiques sera suffisante
pour générer une année ou l'autre 5 ou
10 milliards d'euros de recettes de plus
qui viendront alléger la dette publique
de tempant comme le propose l'article 14
de la loi devons-nous prendre pour
argent comptant les prévisions linéaires
de croissance à 2 % l'an à compter de
2014 et de croissance de la masse
salariale privée de 4 % l'an comme si je
dirais là encore tout irait d'un seul
coup ou presque mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes poss possiblees devons-nous
croire aux vertuus de la progression des
dépenses d'assurance maladie fixé par
l'ONDAM de manière linéaire à hauteur de
2,5 % l'an c'est-à-dire d'environ 4,5
milliards d'euros de plus et cela tous
les ans et voici que le collectif
budgétaire dont nous venons d'achever la
discussion change d'un coup je dirais
toutes les données du
problème que reste-t-il de la loi de
programmation quand on décide d'affecter
20 milliards d'euros essentiellement
financé par des prélèvements fiscaux
existants ou à venir mais aussi par des
réductions de dépenses et des économies
qu'on attend sans doute de la mise en
œuvre de la modernisation de l'action
publique à encourager les entreprises
nous devrions dire les sociétés à à
poursuivre leur conquête de marché à
l'export à innover à investir et cetera
et cetera monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mettez en doute
la fiabilité de la programmation se
fondant pour cela sur les perspectives
macroéconomiques du fameux consensus des
conjoncturistes
hein on pourra dire de ces oiseaux de
plus ou moins mauvais augure qui depuis
plusieurs années mettent d'ailleurs en
question à peu près tous les projets de
loi fin financier dans notre pays
rassurons tout de suite je dirais notre
collègue Philippe Marini même les lois
de programmation discuté et voté sous
les deux dernières législatives n'ont
pas atteint leur
objectif une loi de programmation que
justement avait évidemment soutenu
monsieur Marini et qui prévoyait entre
autres perspective un déficit de 1,5 %
de PIP fin 2012 gr grâ je dirais entre
autres à une croissance du PIB de 2 % en
2010 et de 2,5 pour 2011 et 2012 sans
compter une datte publique qui aurait
alors été légèrement inférieure à 70 %
en fin de programmation je le dis parce
qu'il avait poser la question mais ça
répond à ce que vient de signaler madame
desego euh je vais pas en rajouter au
chiffres et vous accabler trop longtemps
de ces chiffres après avoir ainsi
rappelé qu'aucune qu'aucune madame des
ég qu'aucune des lois de programmation
nouvelle formule c'est-à-dire après la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 n'a
été finalement mené à son terme et je
dirais qu'il est fort probable que celle
dont nous débattons n'échappe guerre
plus à ce funestre destin pourquoi je
dirais tout simplement parce que tous
ces textes sans la moindre exception on
été fondés sur une équivoque d'une part
respecter coûte que coûte quel qu'en
soit le prix les règles d'une union
économique et monétaire dont le moins
que l'on puisse dire et qu'elle est
l'une des constructions les plus
aberrantes qu'il a été donné
d'analyser une politique économique
toute tendue vers la défense de la
parité d'une monnaie qui d'ailleurs qui
s'avère bien plus faible que ne le
pensaient ses initiateurs dans une
économie européenne qui se fait marcher
dessus par l'ensemble des puissances
économiques émerg
sur tous les continents et dans tous les
domaines l'Europe vend moins et je
dirais de moins en moins dans le monde
il n'y a d'ailleur pas que la France qui
soit en cause de ce point de vue elle
est engoncée engluée dans l'austérité et
en plus l'euro s'est dévalué face aux
monnaaies concurrentes orors nous disons
d'arrêter le massacre des emplois
industriels des garanties sociales
acquise par les peuples d'Europe après
les luttes de la Résistance et de la
Libération menée pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et puis pour terminer je
dirais seulement voilà cette fièvre
aostéritaire qui peelu l'air du temps en
Europe va de paire je dirais avec une
écoute vers les marchés
financiers ce qui nous pose problème
alors pour terminer je dirais que le
jour où les lois de programmation se
définiront en rupture en rupture avec
cet équivoque peut-être pourrions-nous
les soutenir
merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
François Fortassin pour le groupe RDSE
pour 6
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous voilà
réunis après l'échec de la CMP pour
débattre à nouveau du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années
2012-207 ce texte a suscité de vives
réactions si je me tourne du
côté gauche de
l'hémicycle ben le fameux TSG est
complètement au nit cependant et c'est
ça nous rassure quelque part nos amis
restent dans la
majorité je respecte bien entendu leur
position mais je regrette que cela les
conduise à rejeter cette programmation
plu annuelle dont l'ambition est
pourtant très
juste de l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle légèrement réfié dont les
effectifs sont légèrement
réfiés ils auraient bien entendu
totalement
approuvé puisqu'il était très favorable
le
TSG et il partage les objectifs mais
conteste le contenu au niveau de la
sémantique c'est assez remarquable
mais c'est pas sûr que
nos
concitoyens apprécie cette ces analyses
extrêmement
subtiles pour nous cette programmation
dans l'objectif est le redressement des
finances publiques grâce à des efforts
plus justes et équilibrés mais elle va
dans le bon sens et c'est ce qui compte
ce projet de loi de programmation prév
donc des efforts importants en recette
comme en dépenses pour rééquilibrer nos
comptes nous restons cependant
interrogatifs sur certains choix et cela
est bien normal
entre la répartition des efforts en ce
qui concerne les recettes et puis
certaines coupes si vous permettez
expression facile en ce qui concerne les
dépenses concernant les
dépenses nous soutenons
l'engagement du président de la
République dans trois domaines
prioritaires à savoir l'éducation
l'emploi la justice même si nous
déplorons par ailleurs la baisse
d'autres postes budgétaires comme la
culture et le
développement durable nous considérons
par ailleurs que dans les années à venir
il faudra explorer quelques économies
possibles comme l'a remarqué à la fois
la Cour des comptes et le rapport Galois
en ce qui concerne les niches fiscales
et sociales dont l'efficacité est pour
le moins discutable et c'est le cas en
particulier de la niche Girardin sur sur
l'outrem il faudra donc aller au bout de
cette logique cela contribuerait
également à renforcer la justice fiscale
et
social alors que nous les membres du R2
nous considérons comme cet élément
particulièrement prioritaire enfin les
économies de dépenses ne devront pas
affecter la qualité de nos servicees
public il va falloir inventer un système
faire mieux en dépensant
moins c'est une c'est cependant un
objectif et une ambition qui ne sont pas
hors de
porté et cependant il faudra pas bien
entend
entendu adopter le même principe que la
funeste
RGPP dont on nous on nous avait pourtant
venté les grands mérites mais de ce
côté-là je crois que maintenant vous
n'en parlez plus guerre messieurs
dames je n'ai pas entendu ce terme de
RGPP bon oui ça m'avait échappé
en ce qui concerne la hausse des
recettes c'est-à-dire celle des
prélèvements obligatoires il faudra bien
sûr veiller à ce qu'elle respecte la
justice sociale et d'autre part la
fiscalité ne doit pas non plus être en
quelque
sorte un frein à l'investissement au
développement économique je sais que le
gouvernement en a pleinement conscience
et vous monsieur le ministre vous êtes
particulièrement attaché à cela
le crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
et
l'emploi change quand même un peu la
donne de cette
programmation et nous soutenons cette
mesure essentielle pour le dynamisme de
notre économie car tout le monde
s'accorde sur le constat nous l'avons vu
dans les débats dans les semaines
dernières la
désestrialisation et les chiffres
dramatiques du du chômage ainsi qu'un
commerce extérieur en berne sont des
éléments relativement
inquiétant toutefois avec la volonté
nous retrouverons les chemins de la
croissance et le cice doit non seulement
aider les entreprises mais faciliter
aussi la transition
écologique et créer des emplois pour
revenir à la programmation des finances
publiques je dirais qu'il s'agit d'abord
avant tout d'une question de crédibilité
personne n'a certes en possession la
boule de cristal mais on on sait que dès
l'instant où le cap sera maintenu il y
aura certainement des résultats plutôt
agréables au
bout un point fait
débat les prévisions de croissance à 08
% en
2013 seront certainement difficiles à
obtenir mais sont tout à fait
possibles par
contre on peut 2014 à 2 % il parviendra
t
ça n'est pas une certitude mais il faut
quand même se fixer des objectifs et on
peut espérer que la grave crise
économique qui affecte notre pays et
ainsi que le monde occidental peut à un
moment donné aussi on sort toujours
d'une crise quelle que soit son
importance pour conclure comme je l'ai
déjà souligner malgré quelques réserves
sur les points précis notre groupe du
RDSE soutient les efforts du
gouvernement pour restaurer les finances
publiques saines et pour retrouver une
croissance soutenue c'est pour ça que
notre groupe dans son immense majorité
votera
cette à la quasi
unanimité votera ce projet de loi de
programmation et nous soutenons monsieur
le ministre merci Monsieur Fortassin la
parole c'était parfait la parole à
Monsieur Richard J pour le groupe
socialiste pour 5
minutes comment
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues je crois que l'expérience du
passé des lois de
programmation qui s'appelait programme
de stabilité loi de programme des
finances publiques a montré que cela ne
marchait pas beaucoup à la fois sur la
prévision des taux de croissance et sur
l'évolution des finances publiques j'ai
entendu monsieur ui ce matin à la
commission des finances battre sa coupe
et je rends hommage au fait que pendant
en 10 an ces lois de programmation au
fond n'avaient abouti à rien ou même
avait diverger de ce que souhaitait
faire le gouvernement l'occasion a été
le traité européen le TSCG et le choix
de des modalités de la transposition en
droit français de ces
obligation je crois que le présent
projet de loi constitue une feuille de
route pour le gouvernement et permettra
le redressement dans la justice des
comptes de la Nation et il définit une
stratégie cohérente et équilibrée pour
mettre fin à ces 10 années de mauvaise
gestion des finances publiques et au
près de 1000 milliards 1000 milliards je
vous demande de bien retenir le chiffre
de dette depuis 2002 le retour à
l'équilibre est assez volontariste
puisqu'il est prévu en 2016 et 2016
c'est demain et à cette fin le
gouvernement prévoit de faire porter
l'effort à la fois sur les recettes et
sur les dépenses madame desg Nous citez
toujours les dépenses mais nous faisons
deux fois 10 milliards d'effort sur les
dépenses de fois 10 milliards c'est tout
à fait
considérable la
conséquence de la mise en œuvre du
crédit d'impôt pour la comp
compétitivité le 6c c'est la
modification du taux de prélèvement
obligatoire qui va baisser qui va
baisser dès 2015 après sa stabilisation
en 2014 en 2017 ce taux sera de 45,9 %
contre 46 prévu initialement donc
presque un point de de baisse et
l'impact sera concrètement une baisse de
3 milliards d'euros en 2014 et 7
milliards en 2015 c'est également la
même chose pour l'effort de maîtrise de
la dépense publique l'effort des recett
se concentrent en début de sur les
recettes se concentrre en début de
période notamment en 2013 et il est
réparti entre justement entre nos
concitoyens la réduction de la dépense
publique qui est plus récessive et c'est
pour ça que nous avons décidé de la
commencer à partir partir de l'an
prochain de 2014
elle est plus récessive que
l'augmentation des recettes et le
gouvernement a prévu de faire contribuer
les administrations publiques à l'effort
de redressement lorsque la croissance
sera venue c'est-à-dire selon nos
prévisions nécessairement optimiste
d'ailleurs à partir de
2014 un mot sur les hypothèses
macro-économique on discute évidemment
et on met en cause les chiffres qui sont
proposé 08 pour 2013 puis 2 % chaque
année entre 2014 et 2017 on peut bien
sûr en discuter c'est tout à fait
légitime nous voyons les fourchettes
qu'il y a pour l'an prochain nous avons
par exemple la barcl lesban qui est
quand même pas un repère de bolchevique
et chevelé prévoit 1,1 % pour la France
d'autres prévoient effectivement en
dessous de 08 04 ou 02 nous nous avons
l'espoir que la conjoncture européenne
va repartir et c'est vrai que c'est sans
doute optimiste mais nous faisons ce
pari optimiste et puis laissez-moi
rappeler vous ça a été déjà dit que nous
avons aussi créé tous ensemble
d'ailleurs le Haut Conseil pour les
finances publiques qui va entrer en
vigueur à partir de l'an prochain
j'espère et que ce ha conseil vous savez
aura aussi enfin pas aussi aura d'abord
pour fonction de donner un avis sur le
sérieux la sincérité le fondement des
taux de croissance donc la France va
sortir de cette période qui a duré
pendant de nombreuses années où au fond
les chiffres étaient lancés
chacun défendait ses propres chiffres
mais il n'y avait pas de juge de paix et
bien là il y a un juge de paix c'est le
Haut Conseil et il donnera un avis sur
le taux de croissance choisi sur sa
validité et on y reviendra peut-être
plus tard il donnera aussi un avis sur
les écarts
constatés je pense que le
scénario est
bon car contrairement à ce que un
certain nombre de d'entre vous dites par
exemple madame desg je m'excuse je vous
cite plusieurs fois mais c'est vous qui
avez parlé hein c'est après tout c'est
une c'est une bonne c'est une bonne
façon de faire
vous critiquez l'absence de mesures
structurelles j'entends toujours ça vous
trouvez que le PACT national de
croissance que le
6c que la négociation que j'espère
fructueuse sur le marché du travail qui
est en cours et qui si elle aboutit sera
une révolution dans les normes
françaises vous pensez que ce qui a été
fait au niveau
européen le rôle central de la Banque
centrale en matière de supervision que
la prochaine loi bancaire vous pensez
que tout ça ce sont pas des réformes
structurelles je pense qu'il y a peu de
gouvernement qui auront fait autant en
si peu de temps voilà écoutez je peux je
pourrais continuer à développer un
certain nombre d'arguments mais vous
comprenez bien sûr que nous nous sommes
bien sûr derrière le gouvernement nous
soutenons euh les propositions qui sont
faites dans cette loi de programmation
et donc le groupe socialiste bien sûr
votera ce texte merci mon cher collègue
la parole à Monsieur Joël Labé pour le
groupe écologiste pour 6
minutes ah
oui je sais pas ce qu'
dessus
ur prés pardon bonjour
monsieur
merci c'est encore au piedv que je
remplace notre président Jean-Vincent
placer qui a tenu la la journée jusque
là mais qui est
souffrant monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues le temps de débat et de
vote de la première loi de programmation
en reflétant la vision à long terme du
gouvernement est un moment
particulièrement important elle trad
elle traduit des signaux forts sur les
objectifs à atteindre au cours de ce
quinquena l'équilibre de ce projet de
loi révèle les préoccupations et les
espoirs de changement dans un contexte
économique et social particulièrement
difficile avec cette loi de
programmation
2012-27 nous pensons qu'il est Essen de
s'engager non seulement dans le sens du
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire mais
aussi et surtout vers un nouveau modèle
de société ou la solidarité nationale ou
la qualité de vie et la préservation de
l'environnement sont et doivent être des
priorité le désendettement est bien une
nécessité mais il ne doit pas
s'effectuer à n'importe quel prix viser
un déficit effectif de 3 % pour 2013 et
un équilibre structurel pour 2016 nous
paraît à cet égard particulièrement
rigide les intérêts de la dette
représentent aujourd'hui le 3ème poste
de dépenses de l'État ceci n'est
absolument pas normal derrière cela il y
a de l'héritage évidemment mais se lier
les mains sur des actions publiques
essentielles à la politique économique
sociale et environnementale de l'État
n'est pas normal non plus voilà la la
difficile équation à résoudre d'autant
plus que les prévisions de croissance du
gouvernement sur lesquelles s'appuie
cette programmation
seront difficile à atteindre il reste
tout de même la possibilité de s'écarter
temporairement des hypothèses initiales
en cas de circonstances exceptionnel
nous espérons que l'on saura se saisir
de cette opportunité le cas échéant
évidemment et non s'obstiner dans
l'échec l'austérité entraîne la
récession qui creuse les déficits qui
légitime à leur tour l'austérité de nos
politiques économiques ne nous laissons
pas entraîner dans ce cercle négatif
infernal nous savons que le gouvernement
ne s'y laissera pas apprendre faire des
économies dans la dépense publique n'est
pas un exercice facile nous le
confirmons en constatant la dimission
drastiqu prévu entre 2012 et 2015 pour
les crédits de paiement notamment pour
la culture pour le logement l'égalité
des territoires et aussi pour l'écologie
en général nous devons vous avouer notre
inquiétude sur les moyens qui seront
alloués à la transition écologique de
l'économie même si nous ne croyons pas à
un renoncement du gouvernement à ce
sujet
l'écologie ce n'est pas une charge mais
c'est une solution qui s'inscrit dans
une stratégie de long terme la crise
économique est aussi une crise
écologique et globalement une crise de
société on sait qu'on ne pourra PL qu'on
ne pourra pas continuer sur les mêmes
critères la hausse des prix des énergies
fossiles et des autres matières
premières est une des causes de la crise
actuelle lesquelles énergies ne sont pas
éternelles tout le monde le sait
maintenant il est donc urgent d'amorcer
dès maintenant la conversion écologique
de notre économie le président de la
République l'a affirmé en donnant un cap
précis en faveur de la transition
écologique lors de la conférence
environnementale nous restons donc
véritablement confiants nous saluons par
ailleurs les arbitrages du gouvernement
dans le sens de la justice sociale en
préservant les classes
populaires les classes moyennes les
petites et moyennes entreprises le
gouvernement garantit l'égalité et la
qualité du tissu économique local
exceptionnel générateur de millions
d'emplois notamment dans l'économie
verte il faut maintenant espérer que la
que la hausse de la TVA n'est pas un
impact trop important sur le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages et sur le
financement de la transition écologique
je pense notamment à la TVA sur le
logement social qui a fait débat ici et
qui refera débat évidemment c'est
nécessaire l'année prochaine par
ailleurs les écologistes ser jouissent
de l'augmentation des crédits alloués à
des secteurs essentiels que les anciens
gouvernements ont trop longtemps négligé
nous pensons à l'enseignement scolaire
la solidarité la justice ou encore la
sécurité publique les dépenses
fiscales diverses niches et projets
d'investissement public
seront mieux encadrés et nous nous en
félicitons la mise en place d'une
nouvelle procédure d'évaluation
socio-économique pour les
investissements de l'état des état
établissement publics et des
établissements de santé est une très
bonne initiative nous souhaitons
néanmoins que cette évaluation inclue
encore et toujours et plus que jamais
l'aspect environnemental à cet égard
nous avons déposé un amendement et nous
espérons qu'il retiendra toute
l'attention de Monsieur le Ministre et
de nos collègues parlementaires car il
peut permettre de réelles avancé
notamment concernant les dépenses
publiques écesponsable et l'analyse des
impacts environnementaux de nos
politiques publiques en conclusion je
souhaite et nous souhaitons je souhaite
au nom de du groupe écologiste saluer
les efforts du gouvernement visant à
trouver un équilibre dans un contexte
difficile entre les mesures d'économie
les mesures fiscales supplémentaires au
sein de cette loi de
programmation je le dis sincèrement nous
avons des inquiétudes sur certains choix
stratégiques et budgétaires que nous
avons pu exprimer de l'ordre de la
première lecture mais nous concédons que
la situation économique je me répète est
particulièrement difficile je crois que
ce sont aussi les arbitrages politiques
à venir qui nous permettront d'apprécier
les mesures promises pour le quinquena
nous réitérons donc notre confiance dans
le gouvernement avec force et voterons
pour ce projet de loi de programmation
pour les années 2012 2017 je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole à Monsieur Jean artui pour le
groupe udi UC pour 8
minutes
sur le
fil monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous voici
en deè lecture de la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle des finances
publiques et malheureusement monsieur le
ministre l'opinion du groupe udi n'a pas
évolué depuis la première lecture nous
allons devoir repousser cette loi de
programmation pour au moins 3
motif si la trajectoire est
bonne le retour à l'équilibre des
finances publiques il y a le moteur de
la croissance qui est totalement absent
les dispositions que vous avez prises
par un amendement sur la loi de finance
rectificative ne répond pas à la
nécessité d'un choc de
compétitivité naturellement vous
reconnaissez la nécessité d'alléger le
poids des charges sociales et vous avez
un stratagème qui s'apparente largement
à de la cosmétique budgétaire en ayant
recours à crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi cette disposition ne nous agrée
pas nous voulons privilégier
l'allègement des taux de cotisation
social pour que le message soit clair en
direction des entreprises et nous
suggérons que le financement de
compensation soit assuré par un
supplément significatif de cotisation
d'impôt de consommation c'est-à-dire de
TVA bien sûr le gouvernement a fait un
pas puisqu'il reconnaît la nécessité
d'alléger les charges sociales il a fait
un deuxième pas en déclarant que une
hausse de TVA n'est pas nécessairement
un chemin interdit mais le compte n'y
est pas et voilà un premier motif pour
ne pas approuver cette loi de
programmation pluriannuelle la deuxième
raison c'est que vos prévisions
macro-économiques nous paraissent
excessivement optimistes
0,8 % de croissance en 2013 2 % dès 2014
et au-delà aujourd'hui l'interrogation
est de savoir si la croissance sera
nulle en 2013 en redoutant qu'elle
puisse être négative manifestement à 0,8
% en dépit des propos optimistes et
volontaristes du rapporteur général dont
je salue la contribution nous ne pensons
pas que cette programmation soit
prudente alors bien sûr il y aura dans
quelques semaines le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques qui délivrera son
verdict mais manifestement les
hypothèses macro-économiques sont
surévaluées la troisème raison c'est que
bien sûr vous demanderez aux
collectivités
territoriales
d'accepter une réduction des
contributions de
l'État 750 millions en moins des
dotations en en 2014 à nouveau 750
millions en moins en 2015 c'est-à-dire
un effort d'liard 500 millions et tout
laisse à penser qu'il faudra aller
au-delà monsieur le ministre et vous
insistez dans votre rapport sur la
nécessité de la
péréquation mais aujourd'hui au Sénat
nous sommes sous le choc de cet
amendement que vous avez déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'article 69 qui
remet en cause la répartition qu'il
s'agisse de la contribution valeur
ajoutée des entreprises pour les régions
et pour les départements qu'il s'agisse
de la péréquation sur les
DMT nous avons vu soudainement
arriver une nouvelle grille de
répartition
qui met en en difficulté nombre de
départements dont le potentiel financier
par habitant qui est le véritable
indicateur de la richesse relative d'une
collectivité départementale et bien
cette
disposition va remettre totalement en
cause un certain nombre de finances
départementales l'amendement très bien
mais
j'attends le vote
final et j'attends et et j'attends le
vote définitif de l'Assemblée nationale
si donc nous devions nous engager dans
de telles pratiques vous comprenez
monsieur le ministre et chers collègues
qui soutenait le gouvernement que
manifestement le compte n serait pas là
non plus dans une équitable répartition
de l'effort demander aux collectivités
territoriales voilà trois motifs pour ne
pas voter cette loi de programmation
pluriannuelle alors bien sûr je sais que
Monsieur Jung a évoqué le jugement que
personnellement je porte sur les années
précédentes faudrait pas s'arrêter à 10
années chers collègu you je pense qu'on
pourrait en prendre 15 et prendant 15
années on s'interrogerait sur la
compétitivité résultant du passage à 35h
de la durée hebdomadaire du temps de
travail je gage qu'il faudra un jour
s'interroger sur cette disposition et si
monsieur le ministre vous
voulez réduire les dépenses publiques et
permettre à la modernisation de l'action
publique à la map de répondre à
l'ambition exprimé lors de la mise en
place de ce dispositif je pense qu'il
faudra aussi
s'interroger sur la durée du temps de
travail dans la sphère publique et pour
les trois fonctions publiques que sont
la fonction publique hospitalière la
fonction publique territoriale et la
fonction publique d'État voilà c'est
avec regret naturellement que nous ne
voterons pas cette loi pluriannuelle des
finances publiques tout en saluant la
trajectoire puisque l'objectif est en
effet de tendre à l'équilibre autour de
2017 mais il faudra aussi monsieur le
ministre qu'il y ait de la croissance et
pour qu'il y ait de la croissance il
faut un choc de compétitivité et là les
dispositions que vous nous avez proposé
ne sont pas à la hauteur de cet enjeu je
vous remercie de votre
attention merci Monsieur
artui la discussion générale est close
nous passons à discussion des articles
je rappelle qu'au terme de la rédaction
de l'article 48 alinéa 5 du règlement à
partir de la 2è lecture au Sénat des
projets et propositions de loi la
discussion des articles est limitée à
ceux pour lesquels les deux assemblées
du Parlement n'ont pas encore adopté un
texte identique en conséquence sont-
irreevables les amendements remettant en
cause les conformes ou les articles
additionnels qui sont sans relation
directe avec les dispositions restant en
discussion je je mets au voix l'article
1er qui est pour son adoption qui est
contre il est adopté article 2 même vote
article 2 bis même vote article 3 même
vote article 4 même vote article 5 même
vote à la article 6 amendement numéro 2
présenté par madame
Beaufils monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je crois
que la maladie de Monsieur placé a dû
faire du du chemin parce que je commence
à avoir des problèmes de voix moi aussi
donc ah non non mais je je n'ai rien dit
dans ce
domaine-là donc mais beaucoup de
collègues touss aussi l'autre jour hein
donc je feraai pas porter un chapeau qui
n'a peut-être pas l'article 6 donc du
projet de loi de programmation vise
entre autres objectifs à produire une
trajectoire globale des effectifs
budgétaires de l'État sur la
législature cette trajectoire ressemble
en fait à une simple ligne droite
horizontale traduisant le gel prolongé
des effectifs jusqu'en 2017 il s'agit
clairement dans la loi de programmation
de créer les conditions d'une
utilisation intégrale des gain
productivité des administrations
publiques à la seule réduction des
dépenses de fonctionnement à commencer
par les emplois de fait nous devrions
constater une réduction d'environ de
points LAN du nombre des agents du
secteur public d'État en en dehors des
secteurs dit prioritaires une telle
démarche met directement en cause de
notre point de vue la qualité du service
public et bien en bien des domaines il
est par exemple tout à fait patant que
les services préfectoraux sont de moins
en moins à même de faire correctement
face aux obligations de service publics
qui sont les leurs que les services
fiscaux auraii manifestement besoin
d'être renforcé pour disposer des moyens
de lutte contre la frautete fiscale ou
que les préoccupations environnementales
qui animent à juste titre la population
méritent d'autres réponses que celles
qui sont fournies par des directions
transverses où les compétences se
perdent et ce noit dans une polyvalence
obligée de même y compris dans les
secteurs sanctuirisés et du ucation
sécurité justice l'état de
fonctionnement par exemple de nos
services judiciaires nécessite
manifestement des réponses plus
audacieuses et plus adaptées ce n'est
pas avec quelques dizaines de postes de
greffi par an pour l'ensemble du pays
que sera réglé le problème latant de la
durée des instructions de fait il
convient de ne pas nous interdire loin
de là de procéder un certain volant de
création d'emploi et de ne pas corseter
la trajectoire des des effets
dans un article dont la portée sera
d'ailleurs assez faible sur le plan
financier probablement aussi faible que
l'a déjà été celle d'une RGPP aveugle et
coûteuse dont le faible rendement va
probablement être anéanti plusieurs fois
par le surcoup implicite de bien des
opérations menées sous formule
partenariat public privé depuis 10 ans
pour conclure je veux dire que le fait
de maintenir les effectifs du secteur
public d'État l'équilibre aura notamment
pour conséquence d' amer un certain
nombre de jeunes à la recherche d'un
emploi à se voir fermer une possibilité
d'embauche je ne sais pas combien peut
nous coûter le fait de laisser 10000
jeunes sur sans travail faute de créer
les emplois publics nécessaires à la
qualité des services publics de l'État
mais j'ai bien l'impression que cela
n'est pas sans conséquence également sur
la situation générale voilà pourquoi
nous ne partageons pas le contenu de cet
article 6 et nous vous invitons à le
supprimer GAV de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur
général alors au nom de la commission
des finances j'ai le regret de dire à
notre collègue Marie France befice que
je ne peux donner suite et lui donner un
avis favorable euh d'une part parce que
comme je l'ai indiqué j'ai préconiser
tout à l'heure dans ma présentation
générale l'adoption tel quelle du projet
qui nous vient de l'Assemblée nationale
euh et puis surtout parce que sur le
fond comme on s'en est déjà expliqué
précédemment cet amendement se serait
incompatible avec ce qu'est l'objectif
de du gouvernement dans cette
trajectoire qui est de stabiliser les
effectifs en gageant les créations qui
seraient opérées dans les secteurs jugés
prioritaires par des diminutions
d'emploi dans les autres ministères dès
lors malheureusement je ne peux que
donner un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le ministre même avis madame bofice pas
d'explication de vote je mets au voix
l'amendement numéro 2 qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour qui est
contre abstention il est il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 6 qui
est pour son adoption qui est contre
l'article 6 est adopté l'article 7 même
vote l'article 8 même vote l'article 9
même vote l'article 10 même vote
l'article 11 même vote nous en arrivons
à l'article 12 et deux amendements en
discussion commune le premier présenté
par madame Beaufils l'amendement numéro
oui cet amendement de notre groupe
complète naturellement notre opposition
à l'article 8 nous sommes opposés à la
réduction des concours aux collectivités
territoriales donc nous sommes également
hostille à leur encadrement au sein
d'une enveloppe normée dans c'est une
mesure constante hein c'est un avis
constant il n'a pas changé hein dans les
faet une telle mesure reviendrait en
effet à privé les élus locaux du fruit
de la croissance économique que leurs
décisions et leurs choix ont permis
d'engendrer le présent projet de loi de
programmation orchestre la mise en
déclin des dotations alors même qu'en
toute probabilité la croissance à peu
près inexorable de la dépense publique
locale contraindra au final les élus à
procéder à des arbitrages douloureux
entre la fermeture ou la réduction des
services rendus à la population et
l'augmentation de la fiscalité locale
une telle orientation nous semble
parfaitement contraire à ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire à l'inverse nous
préconisons de mener une réflexion plus
complète sur le concours de l'État aux
collectivités en vue de donner ou le cas
échéant de rendre leur qualité et
notamment leurs vertus péréquatrices aux
différentes dotation comment en effet
pourrions-nous accepter plus longtemps
que la DGF créée à l'origine pour
unifier la taxe locale puis destiné à
remplacer le versement représentatif de
taxes sur les salaires et qui constitu
un prlèvement sur les recettes de TVA
soit devenue cette dotation de valeur
unitaire disparate qui ne progresse
désormais plus mais à qui on fait
absorber toutes les mesures nouvelles
comme augmentation de DSU DSR ou encore
nouvelle intercommunalité comment
pouvons-nous accepter plus longtemps que
les dotations d'équipement soient
réduites au point de ne plus représenter
qu'un concours de 3 % du montant des
travaux comment pouvons-nous comprendre
que l'État quand il modifie les
conditions fiscales du contribuable
local se son obligés de reporter les
conséquences de ces choix sur les élus
locaux si l'on souhaite donner sens aux
libertés locales et la
décentralisation tout en faisant des
collectivités territoriales les
partenaires conscients et reconnus de
l'action publique au côté de l'État il
faut agir sans tarder pendant toute la
durée de la législature pour mettre de
nouveau ces questions en débat et
chercher les solution au problèmes posés
vous le savez la richesse de notre pays
dépend aussi de la contribution des
collectivités territoriales à hauteur
d'environ 11
% 70 % des investissements dépendent de
leur intervention environ 800000 emplois
sont maintenus grâce aux besoins qui
sont les qui sont les leurs autant de
raisons qui justifie que leurs moyens ne
soi pas dégradés ce serait
contre-productif en terme de recette
pour le budget de l'État mais surtout
lourdes conséquences pour la vie des
habitants dans nos
collectivités merci ma cher collègue
avis de la commission des pardon pardon
excusez-moi l'amendement numéro 4
présenté par Monsieur
Fortassin merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ou messieurs les ministres d'ailleurs
cet amendement vise à rappeler un
principe essentiel pour les
collectivités celui de de péréquation
des ressources après le débat qui a eu
lieu hier et cet après-midi sur les
modifications adoptées subreptissement
en seconde partie du projet de loi de
finances pour 2013 le 2013 lors de la 2e
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale il n'est
certainement pas à nin de souligner que
ce projet de loi de programmation doit
avoir doit faire l'objet d'une
importante déclaration en matière de
péréquation c'est une question d'équité
car si la justice doit s'appliquer à la
fiscalité des ménages et des entreprises
elle doit aussi prévaloir en ce qui
concerne les collectivités territ i cela
passe par des mécanismes de péréquation
à la fois vertical et horizontal et que
ces mécanismes soi véritablement
ambitieux car dans notre
pays il est évident que si la Solidarité
sociale est maintenant ancré à peu près
vaille que vaille chez tous les élus la
solidarité territoriale reste dans bien
des cas en souffrance et sachez que les
membres du
RDSE ne cesseront de se battre pour
faire triompher cette notion de
péréquation merci mon cher collègue
alors avis de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général sur les
amendements numéro 1 et numéro
4 merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues
la commission des finances que je
représente ici est défavorable à l'un et
à l'autre pour le premier qui propose de
remplacer la programmation des concours
de l'État aux collectivités par une
réflexion
d'ensemble on peut répondre que les
collectivités doivent sans doute
participer à l'effort de redressement
des finances publiques et que en
l'occurrence il y a des objectifs
chiffrés qui ont été annoncés et dès
lors il ne me semble pas opportun de
remettre en cause cette disposition de
la même façon pour l'amendement numéro 4
défendu par François Fortassin je serai
également défavorable parce que la
précision qui est sollicitée est
superféatoire puisque l'objectif de
péréquation est déjà inscrit on le sait
à l'article 722 de la Constitution donc
vouloir rajouter dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques une
disposition qui est déjà dans la
Constitution serait sans doute pas
indispensable c'est la raison pour
laquelle la commission des finances a
également donné un avis défavorable
merci même avis du gouvernement monsieur
artui pour explication de
vote et bien mes chers collègues je
voterai l'amendement de Monsieur
Fortassin c'est l'expression d'une
protestation contre précisément ce qui a
été introduit à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'article 69 et qui a été l'objet d'un
débat euh qui a été l'objet d'un du vote
d'un amendement mais euh ne fais pas
d'illusion sur le sort qu'aura cette
disposition vraiment euh nous ne pouvons
accepter euh que les dotations
collectivité territoriales soit revu à
la baisse ce qui est une nécessité à
laquelle nous n'échapperons pas mais dès
lors nous devons prendre des critères
objectifs équitable de répartition de
ces dotations et ça n'est pas la voix
qu'empreunte le gouvernement et sa
majorité à l'Assemblée donc je voterai
l'amendement de Monsieur Fortassin merci
je mets au voix l'amendement numéro 1
qui a reçu deux avis défavorables qui
est pour son
adoption qui est pour oui allez-y
monsieur Mercier qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté et l'amendement
numéro 4 qui est pour c'est pas les
c'est pas les mêmes votes qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté je mets au voix
l'article 12 qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre l'article 12 est adopté
article 13 même vote article 14 même
vote article 15 même vote article 16
amendement numéro 3 rectifié présenté
par Monsieur Labé au nom du groupe
écologiste
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues
l'instauration d'une d'une évaluation
global et uniformiser des projets
d'investissement permettra de mieux
mesurer leur impact et de hiérarchiser
les priorités d'investissement toutefois
la pertinence de ces projets pour la
société ne sauraiit se réduire à leur
dimension socio-économique leur impact
environnemental ne peut pas être ignoré
si l'on ambitionne de construire une
société durable les études d'impact des
projets de loi de finance comprennent
désormais une évaluation socio
économique et environnemental de toutes
les dispositions introduites si cette
évaluation a été jugée indispensable
pour la moindre mesure fiscale il est
tout à fait naturel et légitime qu'elle
le soit également pour les grands
projets d'investissement cet amendement
présenté en première lecture avait
recueilli un double avis de sagesse du
gouvernement et de la commission j'avais
espéré être suivi sur quelque chose qui
peut sembler anodin mais qui est de fond
je vous parlais de siges que l' de signe
que l'on attendait monsieur le ministre
je sais que la Commission a demandé le
le rejet c'est la position de la
Commission monsieur le ministre vous
avez le sort de cette amendement entre
entre les mains nous souhaitons vivement
un avis favorable du Gouvernement et que
cela su soit suivi on est en période de
fête soit suivi favorablement sur
l'ensemble des bandes de cette assemblée
parce que très souvent au sujet de mes
amendements je me suis trouvé frustré
ici mais c'est le jeu démocratique alors
celui-là regardez-le bien il semble un
Audin il a une importance de fond et je
vous remercie de votre avis favorable
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur
l'abbé alors il a déjà annoncé l'avis de
la commission mais peut-être monsieur le
rapporteur général allez-vous préciser
oui je vais avoir le regret de dire à
Joë Labé que cet amendement a déjà fait
l'objet d'une discussion en première
lecture et que nous avions convenu à
cette occasion pour vous suggérer de le
retirer nous avions convenu que il était
satisfait et le ministre nous l'avait
confirmé puisque l'évaluation
socio-économique comporte un volet
environnemental et répond donc à la
sollicitation qui est la vôtre dès lors
et il me semble que si cet amendement
est satisfait il n'y a pas de raison que
je lui donne ici un avis favorable ça a
été aussi le la position de la
Commission des finances temps qu'il
s'arve merci avis du gouvernement même
avis merci monsieur l'abbé pas de
demande d'explication de vote si vous
pouvez ben pas faire traîner juste un
petit complément hier hier après-midi
j'étais au Comité économique et social
de de
de non attendez s'il vous plaît au
Comité économique et social de de la
ville de Paris hier ce Comité économique
et social est devenu Comité économique
et social et environnemental ce n'est
pas anodin ce n'est pas simplement des
mots et c'est la raison pour la hier cé
c'était justement où Stéphane lefold
nous a présenté le projet de
l'agriculture agroécologique où la
France se doit de devenir leader C tê au
au comité économique social et
environnemental de la ville de Paris
prenons simplement exemple là-dessus et
malgré les avis de la commission et du
gouvernement je le maintiens et je
souhaite véritablement non pas comme un
comme un cadeau de Noël mais comme un
signe qu'il soit voté favorablement je
vous en remercie merci monsieur l'abbé
je mets au voix l'amendement 3 if avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est
contre levez les mains n'hésitez pas il
n'est pas adopté amendement numéro
5 il n'est pas adopté amendement numéro
5 quand je dis lever les mains c'est pas
pour faire pression mais c'est pour que
les gens manifestent leur vote pour
qu'on puisse le voir amendement numéro 5
présenté par Monsieur Fortassin merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègue le présent
amendement vise à supprimer la mention
dans la loi de programmation d'une
contreexpertise indépendante des
évaluations socio-économique concernant
certains projets d'investissement public
lorsque ceci dépasse des seuils fixés
par décret comme nous l'avions souligné
en première lecture cette notion pose de
nombreux problèmes quententon par contre
expertise indépendante cela nous semble
beaucoup trop flou pour être inscrit
dans la loi au nom de de quoi les
pouvoirs publics se liraient-ils les
mains par leur décision d'investissement
avec ce type d'obligation l'évaluation
socio-économique par le maître d'ouvrage
de l'investissement prévu par l'article
16 est largement suffisante et n'a pas
besoin de faire l'objet d'une expertise
supplémentaire et soi-disant
indépendante ensuite je dirais que en
général cela va concourir à renchérir un
certain nombre de projets et comme nous
sommes à la
veille
de de la période de la trêve des
confiseurs je vais quand même amener un
soupçon de sourire pour vous dire ce qui
se passe avec les l'empilement des
normes iSous là le Conseil Général des
haute Pyrénées doit faire un pont
au-dessus de la Neste en Haute Vallée
d'Or après avoir fait les tous les
projets on nous a dit il faut déplacer
les piles du pont d'une dizaine de
mètres pour permettre la croissance de
plantes dites dissimulatrices qui
favoriseront le passage à pied sec de la
loutre
et il faut relever le tablier du pont
d'un m pour permettre le passage des
chauves-souris coûte
supplémentaire de cet empilement
normatif 1 million d'euros ah ou ce
n'est pas généralement avec ça ceux qui
connaissent cette haute Valle d'or s'il
y en a ici savent que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on n pas vu des
chauvessouris butter et se tuer sur le
plancher sur le tablier des
ponts alors voilà pourquoi cet
amendement nous paraît important si on
veut faire quelques économies et surtout
gagner du temps dans la réalisation d'un
certain nombre de projets merci mon cher
collègue avis de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur général
sur ces deux amendements TR rectifiés et
5 pardon pardon pardon non 5
excusez-moi le 5 le 5 il y en a qu'un je
je craignais d'être dans l'oubli de
quelque chose non ok alors monsieur le
Président chers collègues ce dernier
amendement reçoit un avis de retrait
parce que l'article 16 propose une
évaluation des projets d'investissement
en de temps une évaluation
socio-économique qui comprend donc un
volet environnemental mon cher collègue
et ceci préalablement à tout projet et
puis une contreexertise indépendante
pour les projets les plus important et
l'amendement propose de supprimer la
deuxiè phase à contreexertise
indépendante alors nous sommes bien sûr
contre cette euh ce retrait euh de cette
deuxème disposition euh l'amendement est
d'ailleurs été déposé et retiré en
séance en première lecture parce que il
nous semble que la contreexpertise
peut-être très utile dans certains cas
c'est même un des apports de l'article
qui suite une préconisation de la Cour
des comptes et euh d'ailleurs le
gouvernement é conforté dans cette
vision des choses dehors de la première
lecture et nous avons convenu en
commission des finances qu'il fallait en
rester là et chers collègues je suis
obligé vous suggérer de de retirer cet
amendement qui a déjà en première
lecture je crois reçu des explications
souhaitaable merci même avis du ministre
monsieur Fortassin vous avez la
parole habituellement je fais preuve de
discipline même si c'est pas ma vertuue
cardinale mais là dans ce cas PRC je ne
retirerai pas sur le principe cet
amendement pour une raison simple après
tout on n pas besoin de l'inscrire dans
la loi si à un moment donné le
gouvernement estime qu'il y a un projet
suffisamment important qui fasse l'objet
d'une expertise il peut toujours la
solliciter mais le mettre dans la loi
c'est se lier inutilement les mains et
je quand j'affirme que on va renchérir
les projets je vous vous donne un
rendez-vous d'ici quelques années si
vous n'acceptez pas mon amend merci mon
cher collègue je mets au voix
l'amendement numéro 5 qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 16 qui
est pour son
adoption qui est contre qui s'abstient
bon l'article est adopté l'article 17
même vote 18 même vote 19 même vote 19
bis même vote article 20 même vote
article 21 même vote je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble du projet de loi y
a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote il n'y en a pas je vais mettre au
voix l'article du projet de loi j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe
UMP il va être procédé au scrutin dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter
pour remettront au secrétaire un
bulletin blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter
contre un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin va être
instant le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite Mesdames et
Messieurs les secrétaires à procéder au
dépouillement du
scrutin
ir
regarde
merci résultat du scrutin numéro 75 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2012 à 2017 nombre de
votants 345 nombre de suffrages exprimés
344 majorité absolue de suffrage exprimé
173 pour l'adoption 153 contre 191
le Sénat n'a pas adopté la loi de
programmation des finances
publiques
min j'interroge le Sénat sur la
poursuite de la séance sur le texte sur
la
BPI donc nous poursuivons en application
de l'article 45 alé 2 de la Constitution
le Gouvernement a engagé la procédure
accélérée pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi portant réforme de la
biologie médicale déposée sur le bureau
de notre
assemblée l'ordre du jour appelle
l'examin des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
relatif à la création de la Banque
publique d'investissement dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur François Marc rapporteur pour
le Sénat de la commission mixte
paritaire merci monsieur le Président et
je vous remercie d'avoir autorisé qu'on
puisse effectivement traiter ce troisème
texte dans la foulé ceci nous permettra
je pense dans un délai rapide de pouvoir
conclure pour cette journée la
commission mixte paritaire chargé
d'élaborer un texte commun sur les
dispositions du projet de loi restante
en discussion c'est réuni à l'Assemblée
nationale jeudi 13 décembre j'en été le
rapporteur avec mon collègue député
Guillaume Bachelet cette CMP s'est
conclue par un accord députés et
sénateurs ayant établi un texte qui
reprend la très grande majorité des
apports du Sénat cela mes chers
collègues illustre bien le fait que
lorsque le Sénat se donne la capacité
d'aller en CMP notre assemblée peut
exercer toute son influence dans le
processus
législatif dans le détail l'article 1er
relatif à l'objet de la banque publique
d'investissement a été adopté dans sa
version votée par le Sénat demeure donc
notamment dans le texte qui nous est
soumis les apports de la commission des
affaires économiques et de plusieurs de
nos collègues du groupe RDSE sur les
entreprise en
amorçage demeure aussi les apports du
groupe écologiste à propos de la
transition écologique et
énergétique les apports du groupe CRC
sur la coopération de la BPI avec la
banque européenne invtissement et enfin
les apports du groupe socialiste sur
l'accompagnement des entreprises tout au
long de leur
développement il en est de même pour
l'article 3 qui portait sur le conseil
d'administration de la Société de tête
du groupe la répartition paritaire des h
sièges des représentants des
actionnaires entre l'État et la Caisse
des Dépôts et Consignation souhaité par
le groupe CRC et par le président Marini
restera donc dans la loi même chose pour
l'article 4 B introduit par notre
assemblée à initiative du groupe CRC
portant sur la coopération entre les
comités régionaux d'orientation de la
BPI et les conseils économiques sociaux
et environnementaux
régionaux à l'article 6 la CMP a
maintenu les apports des commissions des
finances et des affaires économiques
relatif au secret statistique qui devra
s'appliquer aux données individuelles
sur les entreprises accompagné que la
BPI pourra transmettre à
l'état à l'article 6 bis la vision du
Sénat également prévalue ce qui fait que
la procédure d'avis public des
commissions des finances ne s'appliquera
qu'à la Déom la nomination du directeur
général de la société BPI group seul et
véritable patron de la banque publique
d'investissement les articles 3 B et 7a
ont également été adoptés dans la
version du Sénat
finalement seuls deux articles ont fait
l'objet de retouche par rapport à ce que
nous avions décidé il s'agit en premier
lieu de l'article 3 ba relatif aux
intérêts non financiers à intégrés par
la société anonyme BPI group dans le
cadre de ces pratiques
opérationnelles la CMP a retenu l'apport
commun de la commission des affaires
économiques et du gouvernement sur
l'équilibre dans l'aménagement
économique du
territoire mais dans sa majorité elle a
choisi de ne pas maintenir l'amendement
sur le concours de la BPI à la création
d'emploi et au développement des
pratiques sociales responsables ce que
je regrette à titre personnel d'autre
part l'article 4 relatif au Comité
national et au comités régionaux
d'orientation a également fait l'objet
d'un
compromis pour ce qui concerne le CNO la
CMP a conservé l'amendement de Monsieur
Savin sur la représentation de la
majorité et de l'opposition
parlementaire dans la
structure celui de Monsieur patient sur
la représentation des régions
ultramarines et celui de Monsieur Denis
qui a attribué un siège à un
représentant des sociétés publiques
locales et des sociétés d'économie mixte
en revanche elle n'a pas garder
l'amendement sur la désignation de
certaines personnalités qualifiées après
avis de certaines commissions
parlementaires à afin de ne pas
introduire d'ambigué avec la procédure
d'avis publicique définie à l'article 13
de la Constitution qui ne doit concerner
que les emplois de l'État les plus
importants s'agissant des comités région
l'amendement de Martial Bourquin
redéfinissant leur composition a été
conservé en revanche tel n'a pas été le
cas de celui de Monsieur Desplan qui
prévoyait une dérogation au principe de
représentativité nationale des
organisations syndicales et patronales
en outreem les députés n'ayant pas
souhaité créer un tel précédent dans une
loi et c'est leur vision qui sur ce
point a prévalu lors de cette commission
mixte
paritaire en définitive à à trois
exceptions près tous les amendements du
Sénat se reflètent dans le texte soumis
à notre examen aujourd'hui les grands
équilibres du projet de loi que nous
avons adopté le 11 décembre sont donc
inchangés c'est pourquoi en remerciant à
nouveau chacun d'entre vous pour sa
contribution au
débat ainsi que vous-même monsieur le
ministre j'invite bien volontiers le
Sénat à un vote de cohérence
c'est-à-dire à adopter définitivement le
projet de loi relatif à la création de
la Banque publique d'investissement qui
pourra ainsi voir le jour dans les
toutes prochaines semaines je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Marc la parole
est à Monsieur Benoît Amand ministre
chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la consommation monsieur
le ministre vous avez la
parole le
Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
je serai comme le rapporteur assez bref
j'arrive de l'Assemblée nationale où où
le texte issu de la CMP a été adopté je
le souligner à
l'unanimité même si deux groupes
sétaient abstenus je me réjouis que sur
les les bands de l'opposition à
l'Assemblée
nationale un groupe est voté même le
texte il s'agit du groupe RMP donc
c'était positif une beau vote unanime en
faveur de de de du texte gouvernemental
mais est-ce que je peux encore dire
texte gouvern amental tant il a pu se
nourrir des contributions qui étaient
les vôtres des deux chambres le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale et que en
plusieurs points que je que je vais
rappeler ce texte a été amélioré il
parvient à densifier l'équilibre
qu'avait recherché le gouvernement un
équilibre institutionnel entre le rôle
de l'État de la Caisse des dépôts et des
consignations le rôle des régions mais
aussi un équilibre national régional là
où on pouvait opposer la tentation
centralisatrice des uns la tentation
régionaliste des autres nous sommes
parvenus à un équilibre et un équilibre
aussi je peux le dire en quelque sorte
politique tant ce texte a pu bénéficier
des contributions issu de de tous les
ban et je note que à ma place Pierre
moscovicii avait donné un avis favorable
à plusieurs amendements et plusieurs
propositions constructive des des
groupes de l'opposition et notamment sur
des visant à limiter les conflits
d'intérêts au niveau régional ou pour
assurer que les représentants du
Parlement dans les organes de
gouvernance de la BPI soi véritablement
présent donc nous avons là une une une
contribution des contributions qui
étaient importantes et et je veux donc
moi me féliciter de bon état d'esprit
qui a été celui de tous les groupes pour
travailler à l'amélioration de ce texte
et et à son adoption à la suite de la
CMP en tout cas pour ce qui concerne
l'Assemblée nationale je je voudrais
revenir rapidement sur les améliorations
qu' permis le débat parlementaire la
première de ces améliorations c'est la
précision du rôle de la Banque publicque
d'investissement au service de nos
entreprises l'article 1 a donc été
enrichi il était nécessaire de préciser
par exemple que la BPI favorisera
l'amorçage
ou offrira des services d'accompagnement
des entreprises j'insiste sur ce point
c'est effectivement un moyen de financer
nos entreprises d'investir pour la
banque publique d'investissement mais
les entreprises il trouveront aussi un
interlocuteur en ingénierie en conseil
en accompagnement une sorte de
prestation globale qui ne réduira pas la
banque publique d'investissement à un
guichet mais bien un instrument
d'accompagnement global des PME et des
ETI je note par ailleurs avec
satisfaction que la mission de la banque
publique d'investissement au soutien de
la transition écologique et énergétique
est désormais bien identifié dans la loi
et je note également que l'amendement si
important adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale qui précise que la BPI doit
entraîner le secteur privé à financer
les entreprises il est clair que la
banque publique d'investissement n'a pas
vocation à se substituer aux acteurs
bancaires privés mais bien à créer euh
une combinaison entre l'intervention du
secteur public en tout cas de la banque
publique et l'intervention des acteurs
privés classiques qui connaissent bien
nos entreprise de façon à créer les
effets leviers indispensables au retour
de la compétitivité de la croissance et
de l'emploi deuxème de ces améliorations
c'est bien sûr
l'exemplarité là aussi vous avez voulu
au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée nationale
que la BPI soit une institution
exemplaire parité modération dans les
rémunérations respect des principes de
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale il s'agit là
d'amélioration politique euh qui était
souhaitable sur le fond et je veux
saluer le rôle du Sénat et et du
rapporteur de ce texte en particulier
pour avoir voulu que la banque publique
d'investissement soit une institution
financière exemplaire troème de ces
améliorations le renforcement de la
gouvernance nationale de la BPI le
gouvernement ement souhaitait associer
les forces vives du pays à ce nouvel
outil vous y aurez contribué un point
d'équilibre important même essentiel à a
été trouvé avec les régions plus que
jamais la banque publique
d'investissement c'est un partenariat
entre l'État et les régions et certaines
dispositions de la loi sont là pour
limiter les risques de conflit
d'intérêts que des débats ont parfois
soulevé même s'il faut le rappeler ici
là où on peut s'inquiéter parfois des
conflits d'intérêts là où on peut
s'inquiéter du poids parfois excessif
des régions dans le dispositif près
elles n'ont que deux voies délibératives
malgré tout les régions au conseil
d'administration du de la banque
publique d'investissement donc ce n'est
pas non plus un rôle démesuré et de sur
croi on n'a jamais constaté la faillite
d'un seul fond d'investissement régional
donc on a là des pratiques de bonne
gestion qui attestent euh de du rôle
positif et constructif qui sera celui
des régions euh dans la banque publique
d'investissement et c'est en tout cas
une orientation que confirmera le
gouvernement dans l'acte 3 de la
décentral istion nous qui voulons que
les régions assument leur chef de fila
en matière de développement économique
la banque publique d'investissement à
bien des égards anticipe ce qui figurera
dans l'acte 3 de la décentralisation il
y a là une approche d'ailleurs
parfaitement cohérente du développement
économique fondé sur le rôle primordial
des régions sans pour autant que ce soit
exclusif de l'action évidemment des
autres collectivités 5e de ces
améliorations c'est enfin le rôle du
Parlement outil national la banque
publique d'investissement se devait
d'être sujette à un strict contrôle de
la représentation nationale elle le sera
responsabilité du Parlement dans les
procédures de nomination et notamment la
plus importante à savoir le directeur
général débat débat au Parlement sur la
doctrine d'intervention de la banque
publique soumission au commission
compétente des grandes lignes du pacte
d'actionnaires entre l'État et la Caisse
des dépôts et des consignations et enfin
contrôle du législateur sur toute
ouverture du capital de la BPI à des
personnes morales de droit privé autant
d'avancer substantiel qui assureront que
la BPI ne sera ni un instrument hororsol
ni un instrument hors de contrôle mais
bien sous le contrôle des parlementaires
avant de conclure je voudrais dire
quelques mots de remerciement au nom du
Gouvernement et au nom du ministre de
l'économie et des finances que j'ai
l'honneur de de de remplacer ce jour
d'abord à vous-même monsieur le
rapporteur qui avz jouer un rôle
important sur ce texte ce texte vient
après euh quelques des quelques annonces
ou quelques moments importants dans la
semaine la décision de formaliser
l'Union bancaire prise dans le cadre du
Conseil européen la présentation au
Conseil des ministres cette semaine de
la loi bancaire avec le vote de la
banque publique d'investissement il y a
là des engagements forts cohérents
combinés les uns aux autres en faveur
d'une meilleure régulation de la finance
mais surtout d'une orientation de cette
finance au service de l'économie réelle
au service de la croissance de la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et donc
de l'emploi merci donc à vous-même
monsieur le rapporteur comme je profite
pour remercier le président Marini euh
de la même manière que j'ai pu remercier
le président carz peut-être que nous ne
sommes pas tombés d'accord tout le temps
sur tout mais il y a eu en tout cas une
volonté euh d'argumenter et positivement
de de la part des uns et des autres et
j'espère que nous au bout du compte
cette CMP et l'équilibre auquel nous
parle non aujourd'hui parviendra à
convaincre au-delà euh des bandes de de
la majorité de gauche du Sénat et et
ralliera les
voies de l'opposition à ce texte décisif
en quelque sorte ce n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire mais tout commence maintenant
puisque la banque publique
d'investissement sera l'instrument
concret au service des PME des TPE et
des ETI elle mettra d'ailleurs très
rapidement en place un dispositif pour
faciliter euh la distribution de crédit
de trésorerie en direction des PME elle
sera un instrument qui contribuera
d'ailleurs au préfinancement
du cice au service des PME la banque
publique d'investissement est désormais
presque un outil opérationnel l'économie
française en a besoin je souhaite que à
l'occasion de cette séance nous
puissions lui donner l'approbation la
plus large du Sénat je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Marie
France
Beaufils
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues une fois n'est
pas coutume pour ces derniers jours de
session nous voici face à un texte ayant
été marqué par la réussite de la
commission mixte
paritaire la création de la Banque
publique d'investissement ne doit
cependant pas être regardée autrement
que comme la première étape d'un long
chemin en effet quelques avancées
significatives ont été réalisées quant
au texte initial du projet de loi qu'il
s'agisse des objectifs et finalités
assigner à la banque de la manière de la
diriger des choix qu'elle conviendra
sans nul
doute d'éviter que les excusez-moi des
choix qu'elle conviendra sans nul doute
d'éviter que les initiatives des un non
ça va pas ça
excusez-moi non mais ça c'est c'est la
fin de la journée voilà c'est mieux
quand les
les papiers sont dans le bon sens je me
disais ça ne ça ne colle pas
bien donc je
reprends quelques avancées
significatives ont été réalisé quant au
texte initial du projet de loi qu'il
s'agisse des objectifs et finalités
assigné à la banque de la manière de la
diriger des choix qu'elle sera amenée à
opérer dans ses engagements et
investissements sans parler de la place
particulière accordé aux problématiques
du développement local et régional dans
la l'activité même de l'organisme je n'y
reviens pas plus en détail notre
rapporteur général les a rappelé tout à
l'heure ceci dit des questions
importantes restent aujourd'hui en
suspens elles étaient portées dans des
abandements que nous avions défendu et
qui n'ont pas ou j'aurais envie de dire
pas encore été
retenu première question tout à fait
fondamentale celle de la manière dont
vont collaborer à l'avenir des
structures aussi différentes que le fond
Stratégique d'Investissement riche de
ces 62 collaborateurs dont 13 directeurs
et 25 chargés d'affaires et auoséo
établissement de crédit employant 1800
personnes et fournissant l'essentiel de
la force de frappe de la future BPI
group nous avons je dois le dire
quelques craintes de voir les uns et les
autres se positionner sur des optiques
différentes sinon divergente et il
conviendra sans nul doute d'éviter que
les initiatives des uns n'empiètent sur
celles des autres ainsi nous rappletons
récemment que le FSI des sa création
avait par exemple engagé 650 millions
d'euros dans le capital de valaleéo peu
de temps avant que le groupe
équipementier automobile ne décide de la
mise en œuvre d'un plan social et que
son PDG une fois lancé l'opération ne se
retire de ses fonctions avec un
parachute
doré seconde question tout aussi
fondamental le fait que BPI Group n'a
pas la qualité d'établissement de crédit
et que de fait la BPI n'a pas n'est pas
tout à fait une banque et ça nous semble
être le point qu'il faudra traiter
probablement le plus vite possible cette
situation dont nous avions soulevé
l'importance lors du débat général comme
du débat sur article a malheureusement
d'ors et déjà trouvé écho dans la presse
économique puisqu'une dépêche de la jefi
publiée avanthier établissant
établissait disait notamment queoso
aurait sans doute plus de mal
qu'auparavant à se refinancer sur les
marchés la situation de l'établissement
qui était jusqu'à maintenant pourvu je
dirais de façon
importante de la note du triple A de
l'État en adossement pouvait en effet
aller chercher un taux à des intéressant
pour l'activité économique et donc je
renouvelle l'inquiétude que nous avions
formulé au moment des débats ce ranch ce
renchérissement potentiel des ressources
que la BPI serait amené à mobiliser dans
le cadre de son activité rendrait en
grande partie inopérante une bonne
partie du projet de loi si ça se
concrétisait véritablement et ceci étant
bien dommage au regard des objectifs
poursuivis et des priorités affichées
s'il revient plus cher à une entreprise
en effet de financer la réduction de son
empreinte environnementale avec la BPI
plutôt que de continuer à polluer sans
ent avec un financement bancaire
banalisé nous n'aurions pas à ce
moment-là avancé d'un pouce donc cette
question des conditions dans laquelle
BPI pourra se financer est à notre avis
un sujet qu'il faut traiter rapidement
troème constat si les ressources de la
BPI deviennent
relativement sont relativement faibles
excusez-moi décidément ce soir j'ai un
vrai problème dans mon organisation
les oui les ressources de la BPI sont
jusqu'à maintenant relativement faibles
son impact donc sur le segment du crédit
aux entreprises risque d'être un peu
marginal pour permettre le vrai
développement des emplois ces
ressources risquent en effet en tout cas
c'est ce que j'ai compris de ce qu'a dit
Monsieur le Ministre tout à l'heure
d'être obéré par le préfinancement du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi et
nous pouvons donc craindre que les
comités régionaux d'orientation n'ai pas
forcément suffisamment de moyens pour
les orienter vers les choix qui ont été
définis dans le texte que pèsera alors
la BPI si ses
ressources bénéficie en effet au cice
dont le rythme de croisière se situerait
aux alentours de 20 milliards d'euros si
on prend simplement la région
Île-de-France on risquerait de se
trouver par exemple en grande fragilité
étant donn que dans ce cette grande
région un nombre de sociétés majoritair
au regard du nombre de redevables
économiques pourrait en effet être
concerné et si toutefois c'était
l'intervention du CCE dans leur
direction nous serions donc fortement
fragilisés tout ceci montre donc que la
la BPI ne saurait en l'état actuel
constituer la solution définitive et
universire l'ensemble des questions
posées par le renforcement de nos
potentiels économiques le développement
de l'emploi et des qualifications le
recul des inégalités entre territoires
la BPI ne sera que ce que nous en ferons
et il paraît clairement au terme du
débat que les prochains moments
d'échange que nous aurons sur la réforme
bancaire sur le devenir de l'épargne
réglementé et d'autres sujets du même
champ d'investigation seront en tout cas
je l'espère le moment de faire le point
des avancées des limites du texte mais
surtout de peut-être créer les
conditions d'améliorer les conditions de
son
financement merci Madame Marie France
befice la parole est à Monsieur merie de
montesquio
ça va
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le groupe
udi veut mener une opposition
constructive il attend du gouvernement
des mesures en faveur de la relance de
notre économie c'est donc sans préjugé
négatif que nous avions abordé l'examen
du projet de loi créant la BPI car
celui-ci porte sur le cœur de notre
activité économique formé par des
entreprises très petites petite moyenne
et de taille intermédiaire représentant
97 % des sociétés françaises et générant
7 millions d'emplois
elles sont les acteurs majeurs mais
aussi les plus fragiles de notre
économie c'est sur elle que reposent les
espoirs de croissance d'emploi de de
compétitivité la France affronte une
situation particulièrement paradoxale
notre taux d'épargne est l'un des plus
élevés des pays de l'OCDE 16,3 % en
moyenne depuis 10 ans et nos entreprises
peineent à se financer
néanmoins comment parvenir à canaliser
cette manne vers le financement de
l'économie productive c'est un problème
de structure et institution qu'il faut
résoudre la BPI se veut la plateforme de
l'expansion des entreprises avec un
guichet unique en région jusque- là nous
sommes d'accord tout le monde reconnaît
à quel point l'échelon régional est
devenu stratégique dans le pilotage de
la politique économique en revanche pour
le reste nous ne pouvons qu'exprimer nos
inquiétudes comme l'avait fait Jean
artui dans son explication de vote final
en première
lecture le texte issu de la CMP qui nous
on proposé ne vient pas les apaiser et
laisse subsister beaucoup
d'interrogations interrogation sur la
création par voie législative d'une
structure regroupant AUO la CDC
entreprise et le FSI trois organismes
qui fonctionnent et qui ont déjà pour
les deux premiers des délégations
régionales interrogation quant à
l'opportunité de rapprocher de cette
nouvelle structure ubriance et les
produits de la cofas dont la vocation
première est d'accompagner entreprises à
l'étranger et pas de financer
l'économie interrogation sur le capital
social la loi de finance n'abandonne pas
le capital de la BPI d'où viendront les
liquidités s'il s'agit de rassembler les
mêmes enveloppes en changeant seulement
la couleur du papier cadeau il n'y a
aucune plusvalue à créer cette structure
interrogation sur l'impact des normes
prudentielles aux activités bancaires et
de crédit s'appliquant aux structures
privé mais aussi publ interrogation sur
le regroupement sous la même direction
d'activités et de métiers différents
déconseillé par la Cour des comptes il
faut là aussi l'écouter car ce
regroupement risque de donner lieu à des
conflits
d'influence interrogation sur la
présence d'élus dans le conseil
d'administration surtout au niveau
régional leur présence n'est pas un gage
de bonne gestion et porte en germe des
conflits d'intérêts
potentiel voici Monsieur le Ministre
l'essentiel de nos doutes et de nos
préoccupations dans la jeunèe de la
banque publique d'investissement ces
doutes soulignent des failles majeures
dans la gouvernance à venir de la BPI
comment voulez-vous parvenir à un
résultat probant avec une gouvernance
lthorique et criblé de conflits
d'intérêt
structurel comment s'assurer de la
crédibilité de la politique de crédit
d'une institution qui aura une
inclinaison naturelle à favoriser des
projets déjà
préfinancés par les régions le
gouvernement n'a pas écouté nos
propositions en matière de
simplification de la gouvernance et de
prévention des conflits d'intérêts c'est
bien l'ensemble de ces doutes et de ces
failles qui contreviennent à notre
opposition initiale et nous le
regrettons et il nous empêche de voter
pour ce projet de
loi merci Monsieur Emer de
montesquou dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à Madame
Françoise
Laborde ça va
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je pense
que nous pourrions tous nous accorder
sur l'objectif de ce projet de loi la
création d'une banque publique au
service des entreprises qui permettra de
répondre aux difficultés que celle-ci
rencontre pour se financer innover
grandir et exporter l'actuelle majorité
a non seulement donné forme à ce projet
mais elle l'a aussi doté d'une véritable
ambition par rapport à celui esquissé
par Sarkozi avant son départ il est
d'ailleurs dommage que les membres de
l'opposition ne voient plus avec le même
intérêt la nécessité d'un tel projet
projet qui répond pourtant aux besoins
et aux attentes des
entreprises ce texte est d'ailleurs
relativement consensuelle et c'est sans
difficulté majeure que la commission
mixte paritaire qui s'est réunie le 13
décembre est parvenue à un accord elle a
retenu presque intégralement les
modifications apportées par le Sénat ce
dont je me me réjouit et surtout ce qui
doit être signalé souligné par les temps
qui
courent après un premier enrichissement
du texte à l'Assemblée nationale je
pense que notre Haute Assemblée a su en
effet apporter des précisions utiles et
corriger certaines erreurs ou certains
oublis parfois graves ainsi un
amendement de notre rapporteur général
adopté en commission avait rétabli à
juste titre la présidence des comités
régionaux d'orientation de la BP P par
les présidents de Conseils Régionaux le
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
affaires économiques avait quant à lui
fait évoluer la composition de la Bpi en
renforçant le poids des représentants
des régions et de ceux du Conseil
économique social et environnemental
régional toutes ces avancées ont fort
heureusement été retenues par les
membres de la
CEMP associer les autres collectivités
territoriales dans ces comités régionaux
d'orientation comme nous l'avions
proposé avec plusieurs de nos
amendements en première lecture n'aurait
certainement pas été
inutile quant à la composition du comité
national d'orientation cette fois un
amendement de nos collègues de
l'opposition avait été adopté
sous-amendé pour que deux députés et
deux sénateurs représentant la majorité
et l'opposition ou plutôt assurant une
représentation pluraliste selon les
termes retenus en soit membre cela a
également été conservé par le texte
élaboré par la CMP même si je crains que
deux sénateurs ne puissent représenter
comme il se doit le pluralisme de la
Haute
Assemblée les améliorations de l'article
1er qui définit les missions de la BPI
que nous avions adopté ont également été
reprises je pense notamment à la
coopération avec la Banque européenne
d'investissement qui émane d'un
amendement de nos collègues du groupe
CRC ou de l'accompagnement de la BPI
dans la phase d'amorçage des
entreprises au final ce texte portant
création de la BPI est un texte
ambitieux il énonce beaucoup de
principes et confère à la BPI des
missions véritablement à la hauteur des
enjeux maintenant il reste à réussir la
mise en place concrète et opérationnelle
de la BPI les compétences reconnues
d'OSO devraient faciliter les
choses plusieurs questions se posent
néanmoins celle de la des personnels
tout d'abord la BPI regroupera les
services d'OSO du FSI et de CDC
entreprise cette transition doit prendre
en compte les inquiétudes des personnels
dont les compétences sont unanimement
reconnues en outre mon collègue
jean-Pierre Plancade l'a évoqué en
première lecture alors que la BPI doit
selon l'article 1er orienté en priorité
son action vers les très petites
entreprises les petites et moyennes
entreprises et les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire ces entreprises en
particulier les TPE qui connaissent des
difficultés spécifiques s'interroge sur
les outils concrets que la BPI mettra à
leur disposition je me permets
d'insister une nouvelle fois sur ce
point enfin si le fameux guichet unique
répond à l'ambition louable de réduire
la complexité des dispositifs de soutien
aux entreprise il doit trouver une
traduction concrète en l'état il laisse
un certain nombre de question
organisationnelle en suspens quoi qu'il
en soit nous pensons que la BPI sera un
bon outil même si elle ne résoudra pas
d'un coup de baguette magique tous les
problèmes elle sera une avancée
incontestable vers le développement d'un
tissu de PME et de TI solide et innovant
qui fait cruellement défaut à notre pays
et explique en grande partie notre écart
de compétitivité avec l'Allemagne la BPI
aura notamment pour vocation de soutenir
les entreprises pour des projets de de
moyen et long terme c'est très important
alors que les banques privées se
concentrent de plus en plus sur ceux
dont la rentabilité est assuré à court
terme par conséquent vous l'aurez
compris la grande majorité des membres
du RDSE soutiendra comme en première
lecture la création de la Banque
publique d'investissement c'est un geste
fort pour nos entreprises et pour nos
industries sans lesquels rien n'est
possible que ceux qui prônent encore une
économie post-industrielle alors que
nous voyons bien aujourd'hui les affres
dans lesquels la désindustrialisation
nous a plongé un chômage et une pauvreté
accrue y réfléchissent un instant et
nous souhaitons que parallèlement le
Gouvernement interviennne vigoureusement
auprès des banques pour financer le plus
rapidement possible les investissements
des collectivités territoriales
investissements qui sont de nature à
relancer l'activité de nombreuses
entreprises sur l'ensemble du du
territoire je vous remercie merci Madame
Françoise
Laborde la parole est à Monsieur
l'abbé monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues nous avons
dit lors de la première lecture nous
sommes particulièrement satisfaits de ce
projet de loi c'est pourquoi je ne serai
pas long dans mon intervention je vous
promets 4 minutes nous estimons que le
débat parlementaire a été fructueux et
que Monsieur le Ministre Moscovici a été
particulièrement à l'écoute des
revendications écologistes afin que la
BPU devienne un instrument au service
des filières d'avenir notamment de la
transition écologique et énergétique
nous saluons donc le travail effectué au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée sur ce texte
je souhaiterais toutefois revenir sur
des critiques récurrentes faites par
l'opposition à la future BPI celle-ci
pourrait selon certain être au cœur de
conflit d'intérêts électoraliste et
l'objet de pression de la part d'élus
notamment au niveau régional Visante au
soutien d'entreprise en difficulté
implanté sur leur territoire rappelons
tout d'abord que la mission d'volu à la
BPI est clairement d'aider en priorité
les entreprises innovantes dans les
filières d'avenir et non d'être un fond
de secours aux entreprises en difficulté
bien qu'il faille les soutenir
le risque n'est néanmoins pas à négligé
mais mais il existe déjà dans d'autres
institutions et certains s'en font même
une fierté auprès de leurs électeurs à
l'approche des élections je dis qu'il
faudra en effet très vigilant des
rapports d'étapes précis sur le
fonctionnement et les décisions de la
future BPI devront régulièrement être
établies en donnant un pouvoir important
aux parlementaires et aux assemblées
régional dans la gouvernance de la BPI
le projet de loi permet aux élus de
jouer pleinement leur rôle de contrôle
je crois au final que nous avons abouti
à un projet de loi amélioré et équilibré
qui représente une réelle avancée à
plusieurs égards la parité nous nous
réjouissons que le ministre Moscovici
considère tout comme tout comme ce
représentant d'ailleurs euh tout comme
le groupe écologiste et les élus dans
cette assemblée que la parité ce n'est
pas un gadget mais bien une réelle
volonté politique à mettre en œuvre au
fil des décisions pour l'écologie
monsieur le ministre avait déjà enrichi
le texte grâce aux travaux de
l'Assemblée nationale sur ce point mais
nous avons pu également ici au Sénat
confirmer la vocation écologiste Visante
à la transition à l'innovation de la BPI
c'est très important pour toutes les PME
PMI qui veulent entreprendre dans ce
secteur d'avenir quel développement
soutenable pour la gouvernance nous
avons une instance qui prend soin
d'intégrer de représenter les
actionnaires les les région les élus
nationaux tout en respectant la la
pluralité des opinions comme le
désiraient nos collègues sur les bandes
de la droite mais c'est légitime mais
aussi et ceci est important d'intégrer
les représentants des personnels et ceux
de la société civile enfin pour
l'égalité territoriale je crois que nous
avons permis d'assurer une réelle
égalité des territoires en incluant les
zones rurales les zones urbaines
défavorisées les outremèes mais
également en incluant Davant les régions
dans les instances de décision la BPI
doit être un outil ancré dans les
territoires et dans l'économie réelle
nous avons pu constater que c'est autant
la volonté des parlementaires que celle
du gouvernement aussi le groupe
écologiste est très satisfait de ce
texte et votera pour ce projet de loi je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur Joë Labé et dans
la suite de la discussion la parole est
à Monsieur philippe Dominati
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la création
de la Banque publique d'investissement
première des 60 propositions du projet
présidentiel de François Hollande
n'intervient pas dans un contexte anodin
en effet depuis la signature des accords
de bal 3 le 16 décembre 2010
nous sommes entrés dans une nouvelle
aire de régulation du système bancaire
mondial et en conséquence dans une
nouvelle are de financement de nos
entreprises et de
l'investissement cet écart cet accord
prévoit des mesures répondant à une même
logique accroître les liquidités des
banques assurer un niveau minimal de
fonds propres quelles conséquen pour
notre économie et pour nos
entreprises de fait le strict respect de
ces accords induit un conservatisme de
la part du système bancaire français et
européen qui ne peut satisfaire la
demande des produits financiers des
entreprises et donc les besoins de
financement destinés à réaliser les
investissements cette situation est
d'autant plus problématique que les
États-Unis refusent toujours d'enteriner
ses ses accords consacrant cette manière
de cette manière un dumping bunker qu'il
est difficile de leur reprocher en effet
il n'est nul besoin dans cette affaire
de pointer du doigt nos amis
d'outratlantique qui ne font que
maximiser leurs intérêts conscient que
la crise des subprimes est derrière nous
et que les dangers potentiels de nos
économies ne sont plus exclusivement
bancaires effectivement nous sommes
aujourd'hui au cœur d'une double crise
celle de la dette et celle de la
désinstrualisation en d'autres termes à
la baisse d'activité de nos entreprises
induite par la crise c'est ajouté une
crise de leur financement or cette crise
du financecement pour nos entreprises
aussi bien pour alimenter leurs fonds
propres que pour financer des
investissements que la création de la
Banque publicque d'investissement est
censé
répondre la question que chacun se pose
alors est la suivante en quoi ce nouveau
dispositif constitue-t-il une avancée
par rapport à la situation
actuelle mais quel est ce dispositif que
le gouvernement est si pressé de voir
disparaître ou alors de voir absorber
dans ce grand machin qui est la banque
publique
d'investissement le dispositif actuel
d'aide au financement des entreprises se
compose d'une pluralité d'acteurs
doso du fond stratégique
d'investissement en passant par CDC
entreprise ou même le médiateur du
crédit que l'on a tendance à oublier
trop souvent mais que les chefs
d'entrepris n'oublient pas or chacune de
ces infrastructures peut se targer d'un
bilan très
positif d'abord la division du travail
opéré par ces structures est cohérente
par exemple l'activité de prêt pour ROSO
l'activité de financement en fond propre
pour CDC
entreprise de telle sorte que les
entrepreneurs identifient immédiatement
quel sera le meilleur
interlocuteur celui le plus adapté à la
taille de leur entreprise au secteur
d'activité et bien sûr la nature de la
demande quelle critique est mise à
l'encontre du dispositif si chacun quel
que soit son appartenance politique
reconnaî les vertus de ces institutions
et bien cette critique est exclusivement
d'ordre
quantitatif et cela rejoint la réflexion
antérieure sur l'incapacité des
institutions bancairirees à remplir leur
rôle en raison des nouvelles règles de
régulation en effet ces différentes
structures d'aide à l'investissement et
à la constitution de fonds propres ne
sont pas suffisantes pour couvrir
l'ensemble du spectre des demandes de
financement de nos
entreprises en définitive le projet de
banque publique d'investissement n'est
pas forcément contreproductif mais il ne
répond pas pas à la question posée à
savoir les moyens d'action disponibles
plutôt que la
méthode dans ce contexte mîre sous
tutelle des structures dont le
comportement a été exemplaire et dont
les résultats sont séparément
irréprochables alors que la structure
maire n'aura pas le poids financier
conséquent pour assoir son autorité peut
être considéré comme un risque démesuré
au regard des bénéfices
escomptés car je le répète le problème
n'est pas tant la méthode ou la
l'articulation du dispositif que son
potentiel manque de capacité
d'investissement les opérateurs actuels
sont en effet fort capable d'utiliser
avec discernement un surplu de capacité
d'intervention nous en avons la garantie
au lieu de cela monsieur le ministre
vous partez du postulat que le problème
est d'ordre organisationnel et non
financier et qu'une simple refondation
du dispositif suffira à combler les
carences pourtant la future BPI sera un
nouveau dinosaures dont la lourdeur
s'ajoutera une pyramide déjà
impressionnante d'aide aux entreprises
plus qu'un réel établissement bancaire
ce sera un holding détenu à parité par
l'État et la CDC dont haoso par exemple
sera une filiale une filiale qui possède
déjà 1000 collaborateurs et 37
directions
régionales les
PME prétendément à soutenir doivent être
promises à la croissance à l'innovation
au cas capacité exportatrice et à
d'autres critères imprécis la BPI va
donc se livrer à un travail de banquier
qui se fera sur la base de critères
théoriques comme dans toute action
étatique et non pas sur la base des
critères habituels propres au banquier
ce risque que vous prenez en regroupant
différentes structures qui séparemment
fonctionnent parfaitement en une seule
structure pharaonique vous l'accentuez
par le mode de gouvernance que vous avez
prescrit en effet centraliser le
dispositif semble être pour vous le
moyen de lutter contre une certaine
inertie inhérente à la formation d'une
structure de la sorte les antennes
régional devant ainsi se rapprocher des
cibles de votre mesure les PME et les
ETI malheureusement en confiant aux
exécutifs locaux la responsabilité de
ces structures qui ront une sorte de
toutepuissance dans nos régions vous
risquez d'induire des critères de
sélection subjectif dans la désignation
des entreprises bénéficiaires des prêts
et
participations cette forte implication
régionale peut ouvrir la porte à toutes
les intrigues 21 présidents de région
seront là pour distribuer souvent
l'équivalent de subventions cachées il
nous est promis que la BPI n'aidera pas
de canard boiteux
donacte en attendant les arbitrages
appartiendront à des conseils régionaux
qui pour 21/ 22 sont entre les mains
d'élus socialistes nous avons en mémoire
l'investissement de la
région en sur le bimoteur 21 millions
d'euros investis les objectifs fixés par
la région poitoucharante pour la reprise
de Liège avec 5 millions d'euros
d'investis avec un objectif de 1000
productions par mois et finalement on
est à 40 productions par mois ce sont
des exemples très frappants qui ont
frappé l'opinion publique nous sommes
donc en droit de nous
interroger sur la possibilité de
pression nationale et locale qui
pourrait modeler l'activité économique
de cette banque
certains conflits d'intérêts sont ainsi
à redouter un autre problème se pose la
bpéie pourra être à la fois actionnaire
et prêteuse c'est un mélange des gens
très dangereux pour une banque les
effets inévitables risquent d'être
destructifs du côté de la puissance
publique les coûts immenses de la
machinerie vont être
gigantesques la bataille entre
organismes concurrents sera sans pitié
les délais d'examen des dossiers se
surrajouteront les uns aux autres
l'implication des régions sera un foyer
de complication des bureaux devront
imaginer le détail du parcours du
combattant que devront parcourir les
candidats destiné à financer les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire la
BPI pourra aussi prendre des
participations dans le capital des
entreprises cela laisse-il augurer d'une
gestion efficace de l'argent public non
si on s'en réfère au dernier bilan de
l'activité de l'État actionnaire
entre l'été 2011 et l'été 2012 la valeur
des sociétés côté par l'État a reculé de
près de 13 % alors que pendant la même
période le CAC 40 progressait de 5 %
soit un différentiel de 20 %. quant aux
participation supérieure de 1 % que
l'État détient dans une cinquantaine de
groupes non cotés les dividendes sont en
recul de plusieurs milliards selon le
document annexé au budget de
2013 en conclusion nous formons le vœu
que la BPI ne soit pas un nouveau
crédilonnais et le libéral que je suis
prendra pour référence le leader du
Front de gauche comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
l'a baptisé la banque publique de
l'incurie gouvernemental c'est pour ces
raisons monsieur le ministre que le
groupe UMP comme en première lecture
votera contre ce projet de
loi merci Monsieur philippe Dominati
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à Madame Michelle
André
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues notre collègue Marini se plaît
à répéter à lablement depuis quelques
temps que la majorité sénatoriale n'est
qu'une majorité de rejet il nous l'a
redit hier afin de se dégager sans doute
de ses propres responsabilités et s'il
était parmi nous s'il était parmi nous
je l'inviterai à se préoccuper de
l'union de son propre camp et de nous
laisser nous occuper de nos relations
avec nos partenaires ce que nous faisons
d'ailleurs avec un certain succès à
l'espace d'une semaine la majorité
sénatoriale dans son ensemble a adopté
deux texte essentiel adopté le second ce
soir je l'espère correspondra à des
engagements majeurs de la campagne
présidentielle la loi de mobilisation du
foncier public hier soir même et je le
pense dans quelques instants la création
de la BPI deux textes sur lequel le
constat d'urgence devrait être
unanimement partagé mais nous avons bien
compris que l'opposition préfère la
rejeté la création de la BPI a fait
l'objet d'une discussion avancée pour
les raisons sur lesquelles nous sommes
revenus hier cela n'a pas empêché un
dialogue de qualité et des avancées
réelles sur la forme et les objectifs de
la banque afin d'en faire un outil
exemplaire efficace et adaptable
exemplaire d'abord par les objectifs
assignés à la BPI laattention part
particulière qu'elle devra donner à la
contribution des entreprises soutenues à
l'innovation à la transition énergétique
à l'emploi et à l'équilibre territorial
exemplaire aussi par son mode de
gouvernance et de fonctionnement dont la
transparence et l'ouverture ont été
améliorés tout à long des débats
parlementaires exemplaire enfin pour les
autres acteurs du financement de
l'économie que la BPI n'a naturellement
pas vocation à remplacer mais à
encouragé à soutenir des entrepris ou
des projets vers lesquels il n'irait pas
seul c'est d'ailleurs sur cet effet
d'entraînement et sur l'aspect global de
son intervention que reposera une part
de l'efficacité de la banque publique
d'investissement c'est en effet cet
aspect global de l'offre proposée par
les filiales de la BPI qui fera de
celle-ci l'interlocuteur public unique
des entreprises dans leur projets de
financement la BPI ne sera pas une
structure figé certains s'en inquiètent
nous l'avons bien compris le cadre
défini par la loi permet l'adaptation
nécessaire aux évolutions des besoins
des entreprises cependant tant les
modifications de la structure de la BPI
que celle de ses orientations
stratégiques seront soumises et nous y
avons tenu au contrôle du Parlement et
comme certaines collègues je veux me
réjouir du fait que son ambition de
parité c'est-à-dire d'égale présence des
hommes et des femmes en complet accord
avec la constitution de notre pays euh
est une bonne une bonne évolution
mais je voudrais dire à notre collègue
Dominati que quand on parle des régions
comme il vient de le faire et des
difficultés pour leurs compétences
économique il faut se souvenir ceux qui
était dans cet hémicycle le savent que
au moment où nous étions sur le débat de
la loi d'IT trfarin décentralisation
vous vous souvenez sans
doute tout d'un coup les région qui
devait avoir la compétence économique
clairement affirmée et qui aurait sans
doute été très positive ce le son vu
remettre en cause par un amendement d'un
de nos collègues Éric doligliget pour le
citer euh curieusement juste après les
élections régional où nous avions nous à
gauche remporté la majorité des régions
donc il faut pas s'étonner dès lors
qu'il y ait une fragilité en la matière
et peut-être sera-t-il temps de revenir
sur cette question très prochainement
mais je voudrais conclure et dire que
nous nous réjouissons de que les
principales avancées proposées par le
Sénat aent été maintenu en commission
mixte par ire celle-ci a démontré un
accord général sur le texte certes des
amendements portés par des sénateurs
socialistes ont été retirés du texte
final mais c'est le jeu classique de la
commission mixte paritaire et nous
voyons bien combien nous apprécions
qu'il y ait des apports de chacun dans
les commissions mixtes paritaires au
regard de la frustration lorsque nous
apportons une feuille blanche mais les
principales précisions apportées en
termees de mission de la BPI de
composition des instances ont été
conservées nous nous en réjouissons donc
et le groupe social dans ces contextes
votera pour l'adoption des conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire mes
chers collègues je vous
remercie merci Madame Michel André la
discussion générale est close je
rappelle qu'en application de l'article
42 alinéa 12 du règlement le Sénat
examinant après l'Assemblée nationale le
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire il se prononce par un seul
vote sur l'ensemble du du texte
conformément à l'article 42 alinéa ha du
règlement je vais mettre donc au voie
l'ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction résultant du texte proposé par
la Commission Mixte Paritaire y a-t-il
des demandes d'explication de
vote je n'en vois
pas je vais mettre au voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi dans la rédaction donc je
le rappelle résultant du texte proposé
par la commission mixte paritaire je
suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe
socialiste il va donc être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement je rappelle que ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettront au
secrétaire un bulletin blanc que ceux
qui souhaitent voter contre remettront
un bulletin bleu et que ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettront un SC
rouge le scrutin est est
ouvert
merci le scrutin est donc clos et
j'invite Mesdames et Messieurs les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin
le drit est définitivement adopté et
bien chers
collègues je vais vous donner le
résultat du scrutin numéro 67
16 nombre de votants 345 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 344 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés
173 pour l'adoption 176
contre
168 le projet de loi est donc
définitivement
adopté nous quittons l'hémicycle du
Sénat merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
séance prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire c'est cet
après-midi à partir de 14h45 avec Michel
zames vous pourrez suivre en direct sur
notre antenne les questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement très belle journée à
tous
a